Okay.
Which will good experience.
Hello everybody
and Reagan's here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
longtime friends slash standup comedian.
Extraordinary slash a international man of mystery.
That's how I look at you.
Wow.
I like that intro and I'm working with people.
I'm going to start asking them to go with that intro.
Plus you have the only comic I know that works outside of Vegas,
but lives in Vegas.
Yes.
For everybody else's.
The opposite.
Right?
Or they live in Vegas only because they want to work in Vegas.
Like a carrot top type individual.
Yes I do.
I do life and show business backwards.
I want a long commute.
I want to go to an airport and get on a plane and fly more than a thousand miles
away from my home and do my work.
But you work everywhere though.
I mean,
you worked in Va.
Do you work in Reno?
Yeah,
I'll do reno.
He'll do reno.
Just what?
You won't do Vegas.
I mean I might at one point.
You know what I mean?
Like those residencies seemed kind of uh,
intriguing.
You know,
carrot top Rita Rudner I think she's doing another one.
I'm not sure the people that,
but not yet.
You know what I mean?
I still like being on the road.
I,
I to me for now,
that's what I want to be as a comedian,
as a traveling comedian.
He had,
the residencies are very strange because they're intriguing in some way.
I had a conversation with George Wallace about it.
I ran into him at the comedy and Magic Club and he's done with his,
he used to do one.
And uh,
the way he described it,
it sounded like a lot of fucking work,
like a lot more work than you would think.
Like you would think,
well,
hey,
for him it's great.
He just has to stay there.
And he just kinda like,
does it show?
There is no big deal now they,
you know,
they call it four walling it,
I guess,
you know,
so like you have to fill that place,
fill it all the time.
So you're always doing promotions,
you're always doing this and that.
And you know,
like I don't know how much of that he asked to pay for,
but I believe a lot of it comes out of his pocket.
And so he's constantly trying to fill the place up and constantly trying to,
you know,
put billboards up and keep the place pop in and he has to do things in order to
get people to remember him cause he's not out there.
Like when you're on tour you're out there,
you know,
urine,
Cincinnati,
you know Brian Regan's in Boston,
Brian Regan's in Maryland.
You know when you're in Vegas you're just in Vegas.
Right.
So there's a lot more clutter,
you know when,
when you're in La,
cause there's a lot of comedians doing that and a lot of other shows in Las
Vegas.
I didn't realize it was that much work.
So I'm changing my mind.
I never want to do a residency.
Yeah,
I'm out.
I've thought about like a partial,
not a never a residency.
I don't really want to live there but a partial sort of a situation where you do
like a once a month show there.
I think like once a month show there would be kind of fun.
Yeah.
I've been doing the Mirage pretty recent pre regularly,
like did it twice in January.
Um,
but that's just cause I'm there anyway for the UFC.
Right.
You know,
well George Wallace has a,
has a big billboard up,
says a best 10:00 PM show in Las Vegas.
And I love the,
the qualification on there.
I did a residency,
I would put a billboard right next to that best 10 oh five show
or a 10:03 AM 10 oh three show in Las Vegas.
Yeah,
that's a weird qualification.
Right.
Best 10:00 PM show,
some silly magazine.
It's always like Vegas best magazine.
Like where do I find this fucking Vegas Pass magazine,
the Las Vegas Review Journal.
Every year co polls everybody in Las Vegas to ask them what they think the best.
Everything is in Las Vegas,
the best Italian restaurant,
the best Mexican restaurant.
And um,
Las Vegas is kind of like a hodgepodge of people,
like from all over.
And they didn't,
it's not the most cultured place.
So like the best Mexican restaurant or as has always like,
uh,
I'm trying to think of a,
I mean it's not Taco Bell,
but it's like a a bit shaky.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like a chain and the best Italian restaurant is like a something you go,
Nah,
that's not the best Italian restaurant.
So the Las Vegas Review Journal always has to say,
well these are great choices,
but here's some suggestions we make.
Like they're trying to push the culture a little bit.
Oh,
that's good.
Yeah.
They,
they have some pretty decent restaurants in Vegas.
That's one thing that Vegas has by far,
like that's the most impressive is the restaurants they have in the casinos.
Like if you get a steak in Vegas at a big casino,
it's going to be a bank and steak.
I've never had a bad steak.
Had like a craft steak or a strip steak,
you know,
the places and MGM and Mandalay Bay or nine at the palms.
Like,
you know,
some of the best takes in the world.
Yeah.
I haven't done a lot of those deals.
I mean,
I'm pretty much like a home guy.
I'll go hit those places every now and then if I've got friends in town.
But,
uh,
I'm not a guy that really knows Las Vegas inside and out,
you know,
it's embarrassing when friends come into town and go,
where are we going,
Brian?
And I'm like,
[inaudible] street,
they got a,
they got a happy hour there and uh,
then we'll go get a draft somewhere.
You know it.
Yeah.
I'm not that guy at all.
When we were at the UFC this,
uh,
last month,
which is,
uh,
January,
yeah,
January.
And,
uh,
you,
you almost looked like out of sorts and like this is where you live,
man.
Yeah,
it was a,
that was my first UFC fight ever.
Um,
Hannibal Burress was in town and,
uh,
texted me and I had seen him out on the road six months ago or something like
that and said,
hey,
you want to go to the fight tonight?
And,
uh,
I'd never,
I've never been to a boxing match or a UFC fight.
So I was like,
sure.
You know,
it seemed like something fun to do.
And I started googling what boxing matches were in la.
I thought it was a boxing match that he invited me to.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
So I couldn't find any boxing matches.
I'm like,
I don't know what fight he's about.
And he said,
well,
just meet me at the will call window.
It did set the MGM,
right.
Yeah.
So I meet him at the will call window.
He gets to tickets.
He goes,
let's go inside.
I didn't know until we were walking in.
When I saw that case,
I didn't even know what I was walking into.
I was like,
Oh man,
it's one of these deals.
You know?
That's funny.
Yeah.
It was fun though,
man.
It was really fun.
It was so much different than what,
I mean,
I've only seen like little,
I don't follow that.
You know,
I've only seen like what I've seen on sports,
you know,
stuff.
But,
uh,
there's much more art to it too then I expected.
And I was like,
it was just gonna be a brutal,
like a brutal match.
You know,
just two guys just going at it until blood started squirting.
Right.
But it's actually,
um,
there's art and,
and,
and there's a,
there's a science to it.
You know,
it's more interesting than I think somebody who,
somebody who's not a fan wouldn't realize that there's more to it than what they
might think.
Yeah.
Well there's definitely a lot of,
a lot of technique to yes,
but the ultimate goal is the first part.
The brutal stuff.
Yes.
But,
but they don't,
they don't just go out right at it.
They have to figure each,
there's a cha,
it's chess and fighting.
Yes.
There's three ways.
It's a,
it's a,
both of those things are going on.
They're not just,
the belt doesn't mean they don't just start running at each other and you start
pounding each other in the face.
They're waiting.
Sometimes it goes like that,
and sometimes they're waiting and looking at each other and figuring out,
well,
what's this guy?
Is this guy going to be on defense going gonna be like,
you know what I mean?
That there's more mental stuff.
Then I think people might think,
I would like to watch it as someone,
as a completely uninitiated,
untrained person.
I wouldn't want,
I would like to see what that feels like because I've been watching it so long
are kind of like have lost touch with what it must look like on the outside.
But to see like a guy would like to sit down with you and watch it.
You know,
cause I was nowhere near you.
I was over by the payer brougth but right when I was in comedy comedian row man.
Yeah,
you got Tom Rhodes and Tom Rhodes,
myself,
Hannibal Burress.
Uh,
Russell Russell was there.
Yeah.
I mean it was Kinda cool and I appreciate the tickets.
Oh brother Russell's there all the time.
He has a,
he keeps a place in Vegas cause he's there occasionally.
And I guess it's one of those tax deals.
Like Vegas has some pretty sweet tax deals.
You know,
if you live in Vegas,
you,
you pay no state taxes.
Right?
Correct.
So like for your income,
that's,
that's pretty big.
Yeah.
When I moved from California to Nevada,
I didn't do it for that reason,
but uh,
it was certainly a nice byproduct.
You know,
it's weird when you think about,
because that's like a lot of money,
you know,
I think it's 10% of your income.
Right?
And then some,
some naughty like that.
What state taxes?
I don't know.
I don't even know because it's from eight to seven depending on where you live.
Eight to set goes down.
I mean it goes anywhere up to 10 but average it's around eight is state income
tax state.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's,
that's a lot of money.
If you're making good money,
you know,
that's a,
that's,
that's a big percent.
It's like having a manager.
The reason I know that there are no state taxes is that night,
you look in the sky over at the airport and you see a string of pearls.
There's about 15 little white lights.
They're all airplanes and they're all coming in and their land in one eye and
every one of those little white dots is filled with people and all of their
pockets are filled with money and they're coming to leave it in Las Vegas.
I mean it's,
it's amazing what,
whenever I'm flying home,
flights are usually packed.
People want to go to Las Vegas so they're bring,
you know,
most people are not going to win,
so money just keeps coming into that town.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous.
And that way,
I mean it's one of the only places we could think of where you're guaranteed
you're going to have a bunch of people that are going to be risking their money
like and then spending it and then going on.
I mean like it's a weird place when you think about it that it's based on
gambling.
Right.
You know,
and
I saw an ad for a slot,
you know,
some casino was saying we give 97% of the money back on slots and that was like
a,
that was like a,
a selling point.
And I think,
can you imagine if your bank told you that they would give you 97% of your money
back?
We only take 3% of your money.
Yeah.
Like that's a good thing that does come in here and we'll give you 97% of your
money.
But how do they,
how do I say that?
That's not true?
Cause it's just not true.
I mean,
there's no way they give,
they only make 3%.
There's no way.
I don't know.
I don't know if they could,
I,
you know,
I'm sure they can't lie.
So there's probably some technical way that that's true.
But Ben,
it's technically true.
I think it's one of those like,
you know,
there's like a house advantage,
like the house is like a 54% advantage,
you know,
like oh 54 to [inaudible] 46,
you know what I mean?
It's like one of those deals.
So that's probably how they get away with saying it.
You know,
I don't know.
But,
but you know,
even if that,
even if it was only 3%,
that's still guaranteed money for the casino.
Right.
You're going to lose 3% of your money every time,
which is not,
not every person,
but I mean overall.
Yeah.
If people bet $100,000 they only have to give 97,000 with that back.
There was a weird case recently in um,
New Jersey where a bunch of people was ruled they had to give their money back
because they won a lot of money playing this game and the dealer had forgot to
shuffle cause the cards had come pre shuffled and so somewhere along the line
he's players realize that the dealer had forgotten to shovel and so they just
jumped their bets up higher and higher and higher every time.
And then they wound up winning like over $1 million.
And then it was revealed that the dealers had made a mistake in some way,
shape or form and that the players,
by realizing that the dealers had made this mistake were somehow or another,
it was invalid that they won,
which is fucking hilarious.
Yeah,
I,
I don't,
I don't get how some of that stuff is fair.
Like the counting cards thing,
I don't,
I don't understand why you're not allowed to do things in your head.
You don't a lot of think,
you know what I mean?
I mean first of all,
how do you know what I'm doing in my head?
Exactly.
You know,
just based on my bedding and,
and even if,
even if you're correct in what I'm doing in my head,
why can't I do that in my head?
Yeah.
I,
that blows my mind that you're not alone,
not alone.
They can just come up to and go,
no,
we don't want you in here because you're,
you're winning and you're smart.
You're smart.
You're thinking.
Then I did that.
Right.
I think he got trouble kicked out of a place for,
for counting cards.
Well,
Dana White,
the president of UFC,
he gets kicked out all the time.
He doesn't even count cards.
He just wins.
He just,
that's a lot of money.
If he wins too much,
they kick them out,
kick you out.
If you win,
like wait a minute,
if I lose,
that's why there's no,
that's why there's no state income tax.
But that's how,
it's also why those places are fucking gigantic and know when you walk into,
you know,
whatever the Venetian,
name a casino and you see how opulent it is and how beautiful decor and that's a
lot of money,
man.
It's been a lot of money in those fountains that you're passing or shooting
water a hundred feet into the sky and a full show of wealth.
I,
um,
I like watching occasionally they'll have one of these,
you know,
TV shows where they show how people cheat at the casinos.
And one I thought it was pretty intriguing.
The dealer was,
it was like at a blackjack table or something.
The dealer was in on it with,
uh,
his friend who showed up and his friends,
his friend was a cheater.
They were both cheaters.
So his friend put a black,
a cup of black coffee down on the green felt right.
So the dealer who's got a black chip or two in his hand in the palm of his hand,
puts his hand on the top of the cup like this and drops the black chips into the
Coffee Cup and says,
you can't put that drink here.
And handed it back to the guy.
And the guy goes,
okay.
And then takes his Coffee Cup back.
That's $5,
loses,
wins,
whatever,
and then walks away.
That's real cheating.
Now that seems to be like,
of course.
Yeah,
that's,
that's outright cheat.
Yeah.
That's outright cheating.
The counting thing being cheating is fucking ridiculous.
It's like,
what is the game?
The game is yours.
There's 50 what is it?
52 cards.
Yes.
You got 52 cards.
Um,
you,
you're watching the know the cards,
they get dealt.
They had all shuffled up and you just do like a mathematical calculation of
probability in your head.
That seems to me to be like a thing that you should do all the time in life.
Well,
of course.
Yeah.
What are the odds if I run this red light where the odds I get hit by a car,
well,
it's three in the morning.
There's not as many people driving.
It's probably,
it's absurd.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like going up to a golfer who just stitched a shot from the fairway and
said,
Hey,
you knew that was 148 yards.
You,
you thought about that.
You figured out that that was 148 yards away.
You're not allowed to do that.
You just have to guess.
You hit it as hard as you should for 148 yards and that's bullshit.
You're not allowed to be knowing that stuff.
I just,
I've never been in the gambling.
I like gambling on sports.
Like I like gambling on fights particularly.
That's the only sport I really gamble and I don't really know.
I have no,
if I gambled on a baseball game,
it would just be like,
who should I bet on?
You know,
Detroit,
okay,
go.
But it makes it exciting,
you know?
I really think it should be legal everywhere.
I really do.
I think gambling should be legal everywhere,
but I think these should be able to count cards.
I mean,
I think if you're,
if you're smart,
you should be able to count cards and if you can count cards,
you're going to win.
And that's the fatal flaw in the casino system.
Like you're,
you're going to win consistently.
Well,
I think what little I know about it,
I don't know how to count cards,
but what little I know about it.
You have to be perfect.
You have to,
you can't make a mistake.
You have to count every card,
you got to know exactly what's going on.
Yeah.
And then you might end up with like a 1% or something advantage or one and a
half percent or something like that.
It's you have to be absolutely perfect,
I would think.
I'm guessing,
I don't know that the fact on that,
but because it's already a pretty even game blackjack.
Yeah.
It's pretty even as far as all those games go,
they say that the games that like people really like or like craps and blackjack
because craps is just like fucking chaos.
You know,
you're just rolled in those dice and who the fuck no.
You got to kind of know how to bet and when to bet and when you're feeling hot
and when it's,
when it's going in your favor.
I was,
I,
I've only played craps a couple of times.
One,
one time was a,
there were a bunch of comedians in Las Vegas including drew Hastings.
Okay.
Drew Hastings was,
he brought us over the craps table and he was going to show me how to play craps
and I'm standing next to him and I bet on something that what little I knew,
I could tell that it lost,
you know,
sort of [inaudible] itself.
But the guy didn't do the,
the stick thing to pull it.
Like he left it there and I was like confused.
So like a moron.
I,
I yelled at the dealer,
you know,
to explain to him that he should,
that he should be taking my money.
Right.
And I said,
excuse me,
excuse me a second.
And then I feel this pressure on my foot.
Ju drew Hastings just stepping on the top of my foot,
like really hard and he's trying to tell him,
what does he say?
He knows what I'm doing.
So he's like stepping on my foot.
Like,
would you shut up?
What was wrong with what you were doing?
I was going to,
he drew felt they made a mistake.
I should take the money back even though even though I had lost it or just leave
it out there and and bet on that same thing the next time it's their error.
Oh,
so it was an error.
Yeah they were supposed to,
they were supposed to take my money and I was trying to explain that to them
that I lost that fair and square.
Take it away and oh that's funny.
I thought you just didn't understand like what was going on.
Cause craps is one of those weird games where I've,
I've sat and I've watched people play craps for like 10 minutes,
you know,
just as an observer and I have,
I had no idea what the fuck was going on.
The hard soft cotton still don't know you can come.
Like what is it?
Like there's a come right.
Like that's like part of the bed.
I don't even know.
I don't know what any of it means.
I know sevens are good.
Eleven's is good.
Right?
Seven and 11 but then they become bad.
If you get a seven on the first thing,
it's good.
But then you roll an eight on the first thing.
Now you want to get an eight before a seven that's all I know.
How would they assume that people know how to play that fucking game?
You get new kids involved.
You know like there's certain games that like you used to be like super popular.
I don't know if the old folks dominoes and shit like that.
How do you get people involved and craps?
Maybe that's why they have these big giant fountains is because I've got a bunch
of people like me making sure that they'd take my losses away.
I don't think that's how,
but I think that there's,
there's some weirdness to that game that just like,
it seems way too complicated.
It didn't,
Richard,
Jenny used to have a bit about craps.
I think he did about how no one knows.
Like everybody thinks they're an expert at certain games.
What he likes about craps is no one knows what the hell is going on.
You know?
Everyone just can see that no one knows what the hell is going on.
Richard.
Jenny has an album that just came out,
obviously.
He really,
yeah,
he,
you know,
I think it just came out,
when did he,
he died about five,
six years ago,
right?
Yeah.
Something like that.
So I don't know if somebody had some,
uh,
soundtracks of some stuff that he had recorded,
but,
uh,
I downloaded it and listen to it.
It's really good,
man.
He was great.
Yeah,
I took that one hard.
That wouldn't bump me out a lot.
Yeah.
I didn't know him that well.
I knew him and be like,
hey man,
what's up?
How you doing?
You know,
blah,
blah.
Last like month before he died,
like that month somewhere in there,
I was with him on a plane just randomly and he was just happy to be sitting
right in front of me and we chatted a little bit.
He was always pleasant,
but I know he was troubled that,
that's just,
that one hit me hard because when I was a kid,
he was a big influence.
He was,
um,
one of my favorites when I was first starting out and he was,
he was on the tonight show back then.
I believe it was Johnny Carson was Johnny Carson tonight show.
And uh,
you know,
I used to watch them on TV on all those evening at the Improv type shows or
whatever it was,
or Hbo.
And then,
uh,
I got to see him a couple times live and he was really good,
really,
really such a good joke writer.
And when he died and it just,
it just bumped me out.
It's just,
it bombed.
It bums me out when people don't feel appreciated and you think they're awesome,
you know?
And he's,
he was one of those guys just,
he always wanted to be like Jim Carrey.
He won't always want her to be like some Jerry Seinfeld type guy that had his
own show.
And instead he was,
you know,
it was a big time headliner on the road selling out theaters and clubs,
doing a lot of those stuff that you're doing,
you know,
essentially.
But for whatever reason he wasn't appreciated or you didn't feel that he was
appreciated,
don't you know,
but it was depression that led to what he did and it's hard to know whether it
was a career related depression or just something so much deeper that people who
don't have depression can't even relate to.
Yeah,
that's a good point because when you know,
you see someone that's getting depressed about their career are they're really
depressed about their career or they really depressing me in these careers.
Successful as hell.
It's like why would he be depressed about all that success?
I mean,
look at Robin Williams.
I mean you could not have a more successful career then Robin Williams and he
kills himself because of depression.
So clearly it's not necessarily career related.
It's a much deeper thing that people have difficulty understanding.
I don't,
I don't understand it.
Yeah,
he was another one that was like,
wow,
how is that possible?
How is it possible that Robin Williams wanted to kill himself?
Like I just,
I can't imagine.
And do you remember?
Good Morning Vietnam and pop by and like this guy was on top of the fucking
world.
Did you ever meet him?
Yeah,
I mean it was weird how I met him,
man.
I didn't know I was meeting him until like five minutes into our conversation.
He was in the,
he came to the Improv to see me and he was in line with everybody else to take
pictures.
He had a baseball hat on and a beard and glasses.
And he came up to me and he was talking to me about a very particular bit that I
did about how much he loved it and this and that.
And a couple minutes into talking to him I'm like,
Oh shit,
this,
you didn't even know that I have no idea.
I thought it was talking to some guy.
Wow.
You know,
we were talking and um,
you know,
he,
but he was like real specific.
I was like,
wow,
this guy's real comedy fan.
He's like really into like the specific aspects of the joke.
Oh,
this guy knows comedy.
He's like,
I love,
like you really put yourself out there with that pivot.
It was like,
so you like the way you did it?
It was so this and that.
And I go,
oh,
thanks man.
I'm glad you're,
oh shit.
Wow.
It was like I met him.
I don't,
I was nobody.
He,
he w it wasn't like he was meeting me,
but I just met him at the Improv in New York when there were a number of
comedians and around,
and I met him at the,
uh,
outdoor comedy day in San Francisco.
You know,
when there's like 20 comedians on the show when he was one of them outdoor
comedy day.
It's a,
I don't know what it's called,
but it's like a big comedy festival in one of the parks and the San Francisco
outdoor comedy or something.
But,
um,
he was very like sweet and low key and unassuming,
like so different from what you know of him on stage,
you know,
like he was almost like reverential to other comedians it seems.
Yeah,
he was,
that's how I felt when I met him too.
And He,
and he's a guy that had this horrible reputation as being a joke thief and you
know,
and I think in his case,
um,
you know,
to talking to people that were victims of what you know of him doing that in his
case that guy just had this deep desire to be loved and deep desire to please
and deep desire to kill.
And I'm like some comedians they just get kind of addicted to that,
that the killing and they are just trying to figure out what are the buttons I
have to press get this audience to
right.
Right.
As opposed to say a guy like prior who,
what he was trying to do was express himself in this way that you would think
what's funny now are saying Robin Williams or prior now prior the prior was
trying to express himself.
Right.
He was trying to like get whatever it was in his head,
whatever thoughts that he had,
whatever feelings that he,
yeah.
He was trying to get you to understand them.
So you would see like what,
what was so funny about this crazy tragedy or ridiculousness of it is life.
It was like a completely different need.
You know,
like both guys,
every comic wants to be loved.
Every comic wants to be appreciated for what they're doing.
But I think with Robin it was,
I don't think like when you hear him talk,
I don't think,
I don't think he had the same sort of attachment to what he was talking about
assembly.
Right.
Prior did.
And so in that sense it was easier for him to just incorporate other people's
ideas.
Just trying to push those buttons,
trying to push on money,
you know,
and that,
that was his style is just like trying to get you to,
and I used to feel bad for Robin Williams whenever he was doing little
interviews,
whether it was on the local level,
you know,
or promoing a movie.
I think he felt like he had to be funny and every moment.
And,
and I used to feel for him thinking he's created this monster that when he's
doing little local,
not that that's,
you know,
a bad thing to do local interviews,
but whatever,
he's,
whenever he was being interviewed,
I felt like he felt he had to have his foot on the gas 100%.
And it's like,
I kind of wish he felt he could just be real and calm down and just answer
without having to go,
you know what I mean?
Um,
so I,
I don't know that just,
and that's why I liked the,
the way things are progressing.
I love this podcast concept.
I love the fact that these kinds of atmospheres are allowing people to relax.
You know,
you can be funny within not having to be funny,
you know?
And,
um,
I think up until this transition started happening,
there was a lot of pressure on Comedians,
you know,
doing morning radio and stuff like that to just aren't lights on and be funny.
You know what I mean?
Well,
it's also when you do morning radio and no one knows you and you're going into
these local stations,
like how many times have you had done a station where they go,
okay,
uh,
what bits you want us to set up?
You know,
like say a Brian,
I hear you just got back from the zoo.
Why don't you tell us about your trip to the zoo?
It was so forth.
Yeah,
it's a fucking man I've been on.
I was on one just a couple of years ago.
It wasn't that long ago where this fucking guy,
man,
this producer guy came back and I would imagine what it would be like to be a
young comic and to deal with this guy.
So the guy comes back with a clipboard.
I said,
all right,
the guys want to know what bits you want to up,
what topics you
want discuss.
I go,
dude,
I'm not doing bits.
He goes,
he looked at me like,
what do you plan on doing on,
on the radio?
I go,
we're going to,
I guess we're going to talk.
Is that okay?
I have a conversation.
You know,
like these microphones and he just rolls his eyes and um,
walks out of the room,
like in disgust.
You're like,
look,
you know,
look at you,
look at you silly bitch.
You know,
you're living in 1991.
You're like,
you have no idea what radio is these days.
And sometimes I did a radio interview a long time ago and I,
and you know,
I was trying to play the game and it's like a,
I set the guy up on a a bit and it was just as old bit I used to do say,
and I went through to burger king,
drive through,
I felt like an idiot.
I ordered a cheeseburger,
they said drive around.
So I drove around for about a half an hour.
All right.
That's the joke.
All right,
so I'm in the radio station.
The guy goes,
I understand you like to go fast food places,
you know,
it was like a southern guy.
So I said,
yeah.
I said,
I went to burger king the other day.
I ordered a cheeseburger and a guy said a drive around and he went,
ah,
we'll be back after this.
And I'm like,
wow,
that's going to move a lot of tickets.
There's a lot of that's going to sell a lot of tickets out there.
There's a lot of good guys out there doing radio.
There's a lot of good guys.
They're just,
they're cool.
They like,
they're happy to have you in there.
They're happening to her.
But there's also a lot of shitheads that wish they were comedians and there's a
lot of shitheads that like,
they kind of like,
they either want it to be comedians and he didn't have the balls to do it,
or they're judging comedians like,
well,
whatever it is.
But you'll,
you'll see them like trying to fuck with you while you're on the air.
And also some people to think that there's the only one way to get attention is
to conflict.
Get those guys too.
I've been on those morning shows and it's just fucking God.
It's just like that.
But that's just what happens when you're out there on the road when you're,
you know,
you're doing these local shows trying to pump up your,
uh,
your performances and everybody has different skillsets,
you know?
Um,
that was never my skillset.
You know,
I'm not a go toe to toe kind of guy.
And if I get into an atmosphere where I feel it's adversarial or they're,
they're trying to,
uh,
I dunno,
push buttons or see if I can,
you know,
come back at like little lighthearted insults or whatever.
I,
I just,
I kind of shut down,
you know,
I just like to be a fairly decent guy.
Nice guy.
Oh,
do my comedy.
You know what I mean?
I don't want to hurt anybody and I don't want to be into those awkward
situations.
Well,
some people live off that.
Like that's their whole thing.
Their whole thing is conflict,
constant conflict.
They'll create artificial drama.
Like,
Hey,
we're going to get into one of the,
I had this one guy,
like,
we're going to have a fake fight about,
oh,
it was about Carlos here.
We're going to have faked a fake fight.
I'm gonna pretend that I'm,
I'm taking his side and I'm like,
okay,
well we will see how this works.
Go ahead.
We're going to do a play.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like we're doing an improvised play.
Just like,
ah,
see it's just that that whole genre was so limited.
Like the genre of radio itself is so dead.
Like when you have instant access to podcast on your,
on your car,
like right from your car stereo,
like right from the factor,
what you're starting to see now with like stitcher and you're starting to see
these integrated apps.
And I know I'm pretty aware that there's quite a few other companies that are
interested in getting into it and they're,
they're starting to prepare to integrate themselves with,
uh,
with radios.
And a lot of cars come with Wifi in the car.
Like,
like cellular white.
Like I rented a Cadillac,
one of those escalades.
Yeah.
Loved it.
Big fucking giant American monster.
Really comfortable.
And it handles really well too.
I was really impressed.
The new one is pretty bad ass.
But one of the things that was crazy it was the guy was explaining to me that it
has built in cellular connection for Wifi.
So you could set up a Wifi hotspot in your car,
you could work from your backseat with your car acting as a Wifi spot.
So like if your kids are in the backseat and they,
you know,
if it has a rear entertainment system or if they have an iPad and they want to
download apps or a movie or whatever,
you can download it from your fucking car as you're driving.
I,
I don't,
all this technology stuff,
I'm starting to just get further and further away from understanding what's
going on.
You know,
like phone.
No,
no,
no.
I've got an,
I've got an iPhone,
but a Mattel and Ari Shaffir both have flip phones away.
Yep.
Wow.
Are you just recently went back to a flip phone?
I don't think Dave ever left.
Well,
I,
the,
the car I just got,
you know,
the guy was explaining,
uh,
you know,
you just,
but the phone becomes your radio buy through Bluetooth.
I don't know.
I don't even know what that means.
That's so easy.
So I do that.
So I get in my car and I'm driving off the,
uh,
you know,
the lot.
And then my,
my radio starts ringing,
you know,
like,
I don't know.
It was my phone.
It was my phone through the Bluetooth.
Wait a minute.
How long ago was this?
Just yesterday.
I don't know how long.
A few months ago.
You didn't know?
I don't know what fuck park and rang.
No,
that's about it.
You're not that old man.
This is crazy.
No,
I figured out my mom knows that,
but I didn't know how to answer it.
I didn't know how to,
you know,
and I'm like,
start yelling.
That's what I did.
I just opened a window,
whoever it's trying to communicate with me,
I may chat the next red light.
What did you do?
I just kept,
I was looking at the steering wheel and I saw a little thing that said that had
a button with a,
a phone,
like a phone icon.
So I just press a button and I'm like saying hello.
It felt weird.
I'm like saying hello out loud in a car by myself and then I hear talking
to me and I'm like,
God,
this is strange,
you know?
So I had a conversation at a conversation out loud to somebody that wasn't
there.
Yeah,
those Bluetooth microphones are getting pretty,
God damn good.
Now some cars like the really like high end cars.
It almost sounds like you're talking to someone just on a regular handset,
but I had an old one band,
it sounded like I was in a middle of like Madison Square Garden and my phone was
like 50 feet away and I was screaming at it.
I was like,
oh,
it would be horrible like people,
I'm going to record you so you could hear how bad you sound to me.
Is it normal to you now?
Like do you use it every day or do you still are scared of it when it rains?
I'm still only had like two or three phone calls that way through the car
because you know you're supposed to activate.
I don't turn on the Bluetooth part on my phone.
Sometimes I think a bit and sometimes I don't.
So usually I don't even have that on.
But every once I'll go,
I'll turn that Bluetooth thing on in case I get a phone call and then,
and a hope for a phone call.
Cause it's like,
no,
I'm ready.
I know we pay parrot to your car.
I picture you driving like a 1978 Seville.
One of the big long ones.
Nice and slow waving everybody.
No,
it's one of the modern SUV deals.
He drive a regular car.
Yeah.
Okay.
Anti lock brakes.
The whole deal navigation system.
You use that?
I don't know.
He's maps.
Mapquest printed out so
he does not miss guides as red light.
That's why you stop and go where is such and such?
You know?
Remember those Thomas guys,
we have to fucking g two you sank my battleship.
You had to fucking write down like people would tell you on the Thomas Guy like
where are they?
Address was.
Do you remember a trip ticks where you get a trip away and they'd like print out
your whole entire trip to like if were going somewhere and you'd like turn the
page.
Like I got five more pages left.
I get there.
I remember the first time I rented a,
I rented a car that had that gps thing when it was first coming out and it
showed like on a map while you were driving it had like a little triangle which
represented your car.
Right.
And then it's showing a map as you're going.
And I had never seen that this was what,
15 years ago when those first came out.
And uh,
I was like,
wow,
that's amazing.
And I wanted to see what would happen if I drove in circles.
So I got off the highway and went into like a holiday inn parking lot and just
started driving in circles cause I wanted to see if the triangle went in circles
or if the whole map shift,
you know.
Um,
and I forget what the answer was,
but it's either or.
I mean you can be gone either way.
Yeah.
How high end the navigation systems,
you can actually change it.
You can change it so it follows a direction you're traveling or where the map is
always facing north.
So if you're taking a left,
your arrows going left as a map stays straight or you could take,
you could do it so there were no matter where you're going,
the Arrow's going straight and then the world adjusters around you.
I like,
I like the world or adjust to me.
I just,
I remember
I'm going that way.
It's about me and my travel.
This world needs to factor in where my Arrow is going,
plan,
it needs to suck it.
Some of them are really good man.
Like the Cadillac one that I'd done that I just rented was amazing because the
screen was a laptop.
It's huge.
The Cadillac navigation screen and the screen that's on the like the dashboard,
the screen,
like it's not a dashboard anymore.
Like it's a,
it's an LCD screen.
So like all the different Shit like your tac and your speedometer,
it's not real.
They're virtual.
So it's all flat screen and you're looking at it like a digital image of a
speedometer that shows you like,
it looks like a circular analog speedometer.
Right.
And you know,
it goes like whoa.
Like you could see the,
the dial moving,
but it's not all just all digital.
Hmm.
Yeah.
A lot of cars are doing that.
Oh,
it's pretty hard to fuck with like ways though.
You know?
I don't know if you use ways.
Oh yeah.
Ways is great.
That's saved me so many.
Like,
Oh shit.
Cop had head.
Well Tony and I rented when we were up in Portland.
We rented this Cadillac and talking to the Cadillac,
I would start screaming out at you fuck a bitch.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I,
you know,
there's a button like take me to helium comedy club.
It didn't star.
It didn't know what the fuck to do.
But I go check this out,
navigate to helium comedy club.
I just press Siri and Siri goes navigating to helium comedy club and share the
best.
Throw my phone down.
I just listened to the phone like fuck this navigation system in the car.
They're just not as good.
I want to try apple play,
which is the,
where it pretty much just takes your apple screen on the gps.
So you have all the like Spotify or whatever you have on your phone is that,
it's called apple plates and some cars already.
And you could also do it like I'm thinking about getting my forever like an old
Ford Edge and they'd take out the screen and they put it in like an iPad in it.
So then it's just an iPad who's doing that?
A lot of car places are doing that nowadays.
Those custom car places,
they just throw an iPad that's way better.
Yeah,
totally.
What about the uh,
you mean separate from where the speedometer and all that stuff and the gas
gauge?
That middle part.
The middle part where the navigation is?
Yeah,
like mine is that got 2008 and the thing in there,
it's just so outdated and stuff,
so it's pointless to even happen.
So they just take that out,
put an iPad in there with like three g or four g LTE or whatever.
And uh,
so you have internet,
you can make hot spots.
You also have an iPad in there that's way better.
Way Better.
The problem is a lot of those things,
they have a lot of shit integrated into those screens.
Like they have like your,
your mileage.
Yeah.
No,
you're like,
you're,
you're the,
you know,
like the,
the temperature of the car and air conditioning and all that jazz.
Like all I have is integrated into the screen and use of the phone Bluetooth,
this,
that,
the other thing,
like
they have these adapters now for like cars.
So like a lot of like,
like mine has,
uh,
like my health reports are built into my stereo,
so we're like
health reports.
So like you're dead bitch.
Yeah.
No,
you're not good.
You Look Green,
right?
Where,
where it tells you you need,
like you're driving.
I don't want to health report.
Hey,
turn left.
How much did you sleep a minute last night.
Is this real?
How much cocaine was crazy?
Yeah.
It just takes your blood from the steering wheel.
It gives you a little pin prick that's coming.
Right.
Like like when you're grabbing on the steering wheel,
it should have your heart rate already like displayed or you're a all the,
well they're going to be able to give you,
they're going to be able to give you a scan with an APP.
You know,
look for sure there's going to be able to have an app where you could scan
someone and find out what's wrong with them.
I mean it's not going to happen tomorrow but it will probably happen within a
decade.
There'll probably be something you have to wear.
You know like people wear those fitbit's those risks things and the risk things
tell you like how much you slept.
Like they'll tell you your sleep cycle.
Like people are really into those man.
Finding out how deep they slept and how much rem sleep you got.
Yeah.
And those things are pretty slick because they show up on your,
you know,
your computer.
You can like read the readouts.
Like this week I've been getting much more sleep and my heart rate is lower and
this is then my fitness level,
my body fat,
all that jazz.
You can add all that stuff in and,
and you know,
you look at like your life is like,
you can look at your body like the health of your body.
Like you would look at the,
you know,
analysis of a car.
Like when they plug a car into a computer.
Now if you go to get a tune up,
a lot of these newer cars,
they there,
it's,
everything is done by computer.
So they're doing everything.
They're checking your smog there,
checking the way the engine works,
all that shit is just being analyzed by a computer.
You uh,
you talked about the Cadillac Escalade.
I had one of those as my previous car and
somehow I,
on my email I would be sent a monthly status report of my car.
Like if a tire was low on pressure or something like that,
it would come in an email.
How you tell me now,
how about now?
I thought that was amazing.
That is pretty cool.
You know,
it seems like technology things get,
things get easier to use,
like more user friendly and then they,
and then they go to another level where they get more challenging again.
You know,
like when computers first came out,
you couldn't work a computer unless you took a computer class and figured out
how to work those deals.
And then they became user friendly where they're very visual and you just click,
click,
click.
Um,
but talk about televisions.
Televisions have gotten so complicated,
I don't even know how to work my TV.
Yeah,
like inputs and share every single thing,
you know,
it's like,
why is there like nine different configurations of the screen you want
letterbox?
Do you want widescreen?
You want normal screen?
You want five to two ratio,
three to seven ratio.
I don't even know why isn't there just one thing?
Right.
Why don't you just plug the TV in and it comes on.
You know why?
Because there's a lot of people that are real tech tech geeks.
They love that shit.
Yeah.
Like when they do that ces show in Vegas,
if you ever gotten to that.
No,
he didn't need to go to that.
You want to blow your fucking brains out.
I need to not go to that.
Lots of fascinating,
it's fascinating to see like all the gadgets that they're working on.
Like one of the podcast sponsors.
What,
what does that,
Jamie,
pull that up if you can that uh,
that one thing.
That one,
the ces best show smart things.
It's one of the sponsors for this podcast and it allows you to do everything
from your phone.
Turn your lights on,
change your heat.
It's fucking crazy.
You do it from your phone.
Well you're not even there.
I Ha I have smart things.com.
This is a one CS,
a best new,
whatever the fuck it is.
Best App.
Some,
some bad ass award.
Yeah.
It's pretty slick.
We're in the future right here.
This podcast in the future,
like I've asked you to put something up here,
you would just fold it up and do,
we're in HD two.
Can you put a say that Tri caster,
that thing crashes every 10 show
really does crash every time.
Yeah.
Is this something that like,
like plugs into like an outlet that has like a Wifi connection to so it turns on
and off.
Does everything,
does everything.
I'm setting up my whole house with this.
They sent it to me.
I'm,
I'm setting my whole house up with this.
So it all works from an APP.
It's fucking sweet and then someone can hack it in the middle of the night.
Your House turns into a fucking discount.
It's true beauty
and they start playing like Taylor swift
and you can't stop.
It is pretty crazy.
Like,
like drop cam like I,
those are those little cameras.
I put one in my bed so I can record myself sleeping in,
see how many times I wake up because it's got motion controls that will show
when you move or when you make a noise.
And it's crazy how many times I will wake up and say something and then go back
to bed.
Okay,
so there's your body fighting off.
Wait a second.
There's this 24 hours in a day,
eight of 'em you're sleeping and another eight you're watching you sleeping
leaves.
That leaves eight to actually try to accomplish something.
No,
he's not trying to accomplish shit.
You don't know Brian?
He's just having fun.
But the um,
the,
this sounds like one of those poltergeist movies,
like you would see the fucking ghost hovering over you in the middle of the
night,
fucking your face while you're sleeping.
What does that rewind it like one of those,
a paranormal.
It is crazy because like I talk a lot in my sleep I guess.
And when you do talk it's like somebody else is talking,
but using your mouth and voice and want,
you have no recollection.
Lean like you weren't doing it.
Somebody else is controlling your body's what it seems like.
What are they saying to you?
I don't know.
Like I'll wake up and just pick what do I hae my for it and I'm just like,
then I go back to Brits.
But yeah,
it's weird.
It's creepy singer herself.
So awake and talking,
this whole sleeping is very fucking strange.
One of them,
Kelly,
it is one of the guys who's been on the podcast for is a fitness expert.
He's sending me this thing you're supposed to,
it's like a pad that you put under your bed that uh,
oh you put under your,
um,
your uh,
sheets and it,
it chills you down to like,
it chills your body.
Like it's,
it's very cold.
Like you're sleeping in it and is,
I think it's gets down to like 58,
50 between 58 and 62 degrees.
You plug it in.
Yeah.
And you sleep like essentially air conditioned and uh,
I'm like,
I'm looking now like why the fuck would you do that?
Like I want to be warm.
What's the purpose of apparently you,
your body gets the deepest sleep if it's a little chilly environment.
Joey Diaz has always said that Joey Diaz sleeps like you go into his room.
I've gone into his room before,
like when we're on the road together and I'm like,
well this is fucking penguins waddle and out of here.
It's ridiculous.
Like he takes his AC and he cranks it to the bottom.
He will take it.
Like if you go to a hotel and it gives you like 30 degrees or what,
he will literally try to get his hotel down at 30 degrees.
He's fucking crazy.
I've always thought,
because he's,
you know,
he's very overweight and I always say like,
it was probably like if you're walking around everywhere wherein like 10
jackets,
like you would want everything to be colder in your room.
So that's what he's doing.
He just,
he's covered in,
you know,
I think it's her fat bizarre that the human body needs this weird recharge mode.
The sleeping thing,
you know,
for like a third of the time you're alive,
you gotta be in some bed.
Just regrouping and you know,
I wonder if medical people at some point,
whatever,
be able to eliminate that.
You know,
they've worked on that.
They're very close there.
There's actually some,
some various work that's been done on creating some sort of a pill that makes it
like where your body completely resets and you don't need it anymore.
There's a bunch of different options that the people have worked on,
but I don't think they totally understand what's going on during sleep.
Yeah.
I think people that don't sleep,
like they've done some,
some tests on people with a forced him to not sleep for like three or four days
in a row.
You become psychotic.
He starts seeing shit.
You hallucinate,
you become completely out of it.
But that's what you're doing when you're sleeping,
you're dreaming,
you're,
you're seeing things that aren't really there.
So it's either going to take place while you're sleeping or if you don't sleep
while you're awake.
I wonder if it's the same effect I to have to like if they measure your
chemicals,
the chemicals in your brain and wonder if it's the same thing that's going on
when they do those sleep deprivation studies.
Cause people just,
they get like close to heart attacks,
they look ready to die.
You will die if you don't get enough sleep.
Yeah.
I just wonder what the,
uh,
I,
I'm sure there are dream experts who work on this,
but I'm fascinated with what's going on when someone's dreaming.
What,
what is the purpose of the dream and what is it,
uh,
you know,
what,
what is it helping you with when you're awake?
You know,
if you have a dream that has anxiety in it or if you have a dream where you're
being chased or you know,
any of these typical dreams that people have.
What I just wonder what is that,
what is the purpose of that?
Your,
your brain and your body is doing that for a reason?
Well,
I have work related dream.
Sometimes I need to,
those work related dreams are almost always related to actual concerns that I
have in real life.
Like I'll have work related dreams that are like forget my material and it might
be because I haven't been working like I took a week off or something like that.
And although I know like externally I know like,
or I shouldn't say externally like I know consciously that like if I'm going to
do a show like say on Friday and I haven't worked for a week or so,
I'll do a few tuneup shows,
I'll do a show on Wednesday or showing Thursday,
I'll go over my material,
listen to recordings,
but my brain doesn't trust that I'm actually going to do that.
So if I haven't worked for a week,
my brain like dude you don't even remember even knew she knew her.
A bunch of people who had to see you.
You don't even remember this new shit you're working on,
you know and my brand like I didn't remember my new shit stop.
I've got,
I've written down,
I've got recordings but you brain doesn't want to hear that.
Your brain's like listen fucker,
you better stay on the ball constantly and he little weird thing that you might
have in the back of your head that could possibly go wrong.
That'll be brought to the forefront while you're sleeping.
For some reason.
I have a lot of dreams about shows,
but they're always pre show.
They're never,
they're never me on stage.
It's always assessing,
assessing the situation.
It's always looking at the crowd,
looking at where the,
how the tables are set up,
looking at the lighting and it's all pre,
I don't know why.
Those are the dreams that I never hit the stage in the dreams.
How many dreams do you have?
Appreciate it.
I've probably had,
I dunno,
Gosh,
a hundred in my life really.
That's strange.
And they're all pre show,
you know,
walking around while the other guys on stage and peeking out the side and trying
to see if people are focused and uh,
and yet in real life I don't really have that anxiety.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
It's not part of my,
maybe a little bit,
but not to the degree that it happens in my dreams.
That's so strange.
Yeah.
Dictionaries or bibles where like if you're flying,
that means you're trying to reach something in your life that still,
you know,
hard to get to and stuff you've ever looked at.
One of those and tried to find that.
Well,
some of it I do kind of by the flying one I do,
but drowning,
maybe I and I,
I used to have the flying dreams,
which I don't have any more.
When I was young,
I used to have this very bizarre recurring dream that I was the only one that
figured out how to fly.
And it was all about,
no,
no.
It was a very gentle flight.
It was trusting a gentle breeze.
So bizarre.
I was the only one that knew it could be like a three,
four mile an hour breeze.
I knew how to face it and trust it.
I had to lean forward into it and then just lift my feet and then I would just
start kind of going up like a balloon,
very gently and everybody would go,
what the hell is going on here?
It was strange,
but I was the only one that knew how to do it.
Like no one else could figure
it out,
but it was a trusting.
It was,
I had to trust that I could do it.
That's so strange.
Bizarre dream.
Yeah.
I'm always trying to it.
I always had the flying one,
but it was always very violent trying to,
didn't try to stay up there.
The add China did our oven bird flapping wing type thing,
so uh,
yeah.
Everybody wants to fly.
Everybody wants to be able to breathe under water.
Those are two big ones.
I don't have that.
Never had that.
I don't have the water one.
No,
I've had that one.
I've had the flying one and the breathing under water one.
Hmm.
Yeah,
it's a,
those are like recurring archetypes or
themes to dreams and I want to sex.
It's also,
do you guys have reoccurring?
Like,
like how did that soundtrack and your and your dreams.
Oh,
okay.
Do you guys get recurring like,
like houses that,
what's that sound?
You guys hear that?
Did I do something?
Yeah.
What is that?
What happened?
You don't hear that Jamie.
Okay,
that sounds good.
I think that's your,
a tri caster about the shit and our mouth.
You're about to have a sex dream and it's a soundtrack starting to warm up.
Wow.
That's,
that's an awful sound.
Is that coming through?
What'd you just do?
It's that move your move your laptop look at at a weird,
well it's on the laptops.
On the microphone.
Okay,
well that's weird.
Yeah,
it's on the mic.
Cable.
What makes sense?
Do you guys have reoccurring?
Like why the fuck did you just do there?
What do you hear that,
that crackle.
Whoa was only my son.
Oh,
I didn't hear that one.
We've got a ghost.
That was your spine.
Crazy crackle.
Uh,
do you guys have reoccurring places in your dreams that don't even make like I
have a place that every time I go to I'm like,
oh,
met this place again.
But it's not my house.
It's not a place I've been to.
It's just a reoccurring environment isn't it?
Like what does it look like?
It's a hotel that's really,
really tall and the elevator is really fast and it's just like this old haunted
hotel.
And I always go to the same hotel and it,
it's not a real hotel I that I think of,
but ever since I was a kid,
exact same hotel and I'll have that dream like once a year where I go to this
weird hotel
I,
that hotel is in my dream,
but I'm gently,
gently,
gently loading past diaper.
He asked and I just look over and I kind of wave at you down there and you're
flying up and down town.
It's like telling your terror,
Disneyland,
terrorized.
I can see you terrorized over there,
but I'm just gently enjoying life.
Have you ever done that?
Tower of terror.
Disneyland,
California Adventures.
Fucking awesome.
That's what it is.
It's a haunted hotel elevator,
which sounds like,
yeah,
that's what I was thinking when you were describing it.
You're,
that's the tower of terror.
Maybe it's a dope elevator ride if you ever on it.
Yeah,
it's really fun.
It's not the haunted mansion out anywhere.
It stretches tower of terror.
It said California.
Great Adventure,
Huh?
California ventures.
Whatever the fuck it is,
and you,
you get on this elevator and it tells you the story.
It shows.
It's like some rod sterling type dude pretending to be the twilight zone guy.
Right.
And he tells you the whole story about these people that got zapped by
electricity and the lightening bolt came and hit the elevator and killed them
and turn them into ghosts and now they're fucking haunted and the elevator is
haunted and you go flying up,
flying down.
Yeah.
You literally,
your ass comes off the seat,
you have to strap in,
but your ass literally comes up off the seat because you'd go down so quickly.
You go down faster than gravity.
Yeah,
you should do that.
No,
I don't want to do that.
It's fun.
What if dreams are the real world and this is our,
the actual fake flows.
Creams.
Show me love.
What apps,
what are you talking about?
That's a tough one.
Dreams of the real world.
Well,
there's no idea.
There's no,
no one has any idea what the fuck is going on.
When you close your eyes and wake up in the morning and you've got a whole new
day,
that consciousness,
whatever it is,
you know,
unconscious consciousness,
that state of mind,
whatever it is,
why you're sleeping,
it's very,
very poorly understood.
We know that there's all sorts of chemicals floating around inside the brain.
While that's happening,
there's rem sleep and all these different neurotransmitters that are buzzing
around your your system,
but we don't really know what's going on.
We don't,
you know,
when you have like deep,
we assume that it's connected to various anxieties and wants and needs and those
are like the source of your dreams,
but at the end of the day,
it's a lot of fucking speculating.
There's a lot of speculating as to what's happening while you're dreaming
software updates.
It could be,
it could be that there's,
it could be that we have this idea and this is where it gets real weird,
right?
We have this idea that like everything that is in this world,
we touch things and you pick things up and you weigh things,
you measure things that that's the only way things can be real.
The only way things can be real is if you can measure them,
weigh them,
and put them in,
put them in a box and carry them around.
But that's our own prejudice because that's how we live most of our conscious
life.
We live most of our conscious life with very hard physical things.
But if you could just abandon that for a moment and just imagine a world where
you don't have physical things that you pick up.
Would it be possible to exist only in a state of thought would it?
Would it be possible that the mind is another environment or what you're
thinking about in your imagination is another environment.
It's just you don't,
there's no solid things there.
That's weird.
Yeah.
I mean that's really what
ooky well,
here's one thing.
You know,
you talk about what's real and what's not real.
I,
I've had many moments in my dreams where I'm trying to decide if it's real or
not and I come to the conclusion that it is real okay.
And then in my dream to do,
and then when I wake up,
you know,
we're in a different plane of existence where I go,
okay,
that was a dream,
but why wasn't that real while it was happening,
if I made the,
if I came to the conclusion that that was real while I was experiencing it,
I mean that's as,
that was as real
at that time.
As later when I'm awake.
Yeah.
Why are you not trusting your dream self and only trusting your this self?
Well,
because of the south was there all the time.
Anyway,
I'm going to be at the chuckle hut.
Saturday.
I got two shows.
Friday to Saturday
is a weird world.
The world of dreams is a world weird world of all these people analyze them.
All of these people debate what's going on.
I feel like I gave away my breeze dream.
Now everyone is going to be that now.
Now when I'm dreaming it,
I'm going to look around.
Everybody's going to be around me floating around going,
hey,
thanks for the tip.
We didn't realize you just had to trust it.
I'm good.
Darn it.
Now it's all crowded up here,
man.
One of these days I'm going to figure out how to do lucid dreaming.
I'm going to sit down with someone who actually is a real legit lucid dreamer
and have a conversation with them about it because the people that are there
techniques that you can practice in their states of mind that you can get
yourself into,
allegedly,
I've never experienced it other than accidentally,
but when you have dreams so you can control those dreams and that you could
navigate and create things that happen in your dreams,
be aware of the fact that you're doing it like that it's a skill and that you
could develop it.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I've never,
I've had dreams that are lucid dreams,
but totally accidentally.
And uh,
one of the ways that I learned was one of those movies was whacking move.
He's like,
what the bleep?
Do we know one of those through the rabbit rabbit hole or something like that.
But,
uh,
the guy was talking about lucid dreams and he was saying that you have them all
the time.
You don't just don't realize you're having.
Um,
the one way to determine it is in your real life,
your conscious state,
when you walk through a doorway,
knock on the side of the door and say,
am I dreaming?
Like every time you walk through a doorway,
cool.
Am I dreaming?
And because you do it consciously all the time,
if you do it all the time,
am I dreaming?
Am I dreaming?
You're going to do it in your sleep and then your sleep,
you're going to get to the doorway and you gotta go am Mike Dreaming?
Oh my God,
I'm dreaming.
You're going to,
it's going to go right through it,
but you're going to stay awake.
I did it once,
just once.
I only did that once.
I never really,
most of the time I'm tired.
I'm like,
fuck,
I'm going to sleep.
You know?
I just don't know.
I don't deal.
But if you're one of those people that practices that on a daily basis,
apparently you can get really good at it and you can make all sorts of crazy
things happen and you live in like these wild sex orgy dreams where you could do
whatever you want.
You fly around,
you live in space,
she hang out with robots,
you do whatever the fuck you,
I want to get an an orgy with robots.
Well,
there's enough people talking about lucid dreaming and it's not bullshit.
I mean there's Freddy does it,
Freddy Lockhart,
doesn't he?
Yeah,
he reads all the books and he practices it all the time.
Hmm.
I remember talking to somebody years ago who said she could ask stroll project.
I don't know if I'm pronouncing that right.
A S T r a l squirt from the butt ass.
Yes.
She'd say,
excuse me,
I have to go astral project.
I'll be back in a couple minutes.
No.
Um,
this was a right word,
but maybe I've got it wrong.
No,
she said she would go somewhere.
This astro in her head,
but like leave her physical body and she'd be above her body and go somewhere
else and be aware of it and then she could come back into her body.
Was this while she was awake or sleeping?
Uh,
no.
I think it was while she was awake.
It's a phrenic.
Maybe that was it.
Probably similar as to a lucid dream.
You know,
you're creating this artificial reality or maybe look,
you're seeing things right.
I mean,
just because you can't,
again,
put those things on a scale and weigh them and measure them.
It doesn't mean you're not having that actual experience.
So when you're closing your eyes,
you're meditating and you project yourself above your body,
who knows what the fuck is really going on?
You obviously we think that you're just imagining shit and the shit that you're
imagining is not real,
but it might very well be that we're just so enamored by the state of things
being solid that we don't think that unless you could touch something and feel
it and put it on a scale and measure with a tape ruler,
it's not real.
I,
I'm interested in the concept too,
that most things are a facade like we are,
we're enjoying or experiencing something that isn't there.
When we watch a football game on a big screen TV,
those football players aren't there.
They're at another location,
but we are experiencing it as if we were there.
You talked about the car and the fake,
the fake gauges.
You know,
you're looking at a facade and it's,
you get right down to human beings.
I mean we have the,
the skin and muscles and eyes,
but like right past that is this bizarre s skull and muscle thing.
So what is the real,
you know what I mean?
We're looking at a facade that we're comfortable with,
but what is an inch beyond that?
It's a scary,
scary thing,
but I think we need facades that we can be comfortable with to be able to
experience life in a way that isn't scary.
Yeah.
Like I think about you,
Brian Regan,
I know you,
I know your personality,
but deep into your head there's this bunch of weird synapses that are firing
your life experiences is all like manifesting itself in your actions and your
behavior and this is a,
it's a very weird thing to be a person.
Very,
very weird thing.
Yeah,
but that's a really good way of looking at it.
It's like you're projecting it.
That's why weirds us out when whenever someone like does weird shit with their
face.
You know,
like when whenever someone gets their lips done or gets her cheeks puffed up
with that weird shit that they do,
man,
that freaks me out.
That freaks me out more than almost anything when it,
when it's people get stuff putting her face and nurture for like,
it's like,
what do you,
you know,
it's,
you're confusing me.
I can't,
I'm used to this certain facility.
It doesn't mind.
I don't mind aging.
I don't mind if it changes over time.
That all seemed normal.
When you start putting stuff in there and pumping things up and botoxing shit
and stuff
that weirds people out because it's like,
man,
I'm missing the signals off fucking screw.
Where it's like,
if you can't have the normal facial reactions to express the proper emotions,
yeah.
The signals are getting all cross.
That is a weird one.
When they have the rubber in their face and their face doesn't move.
Right.
Like I remember we were at the Bray Improv and uh,
Joan Rivers rest,
her soul was on television two.
She had a reality show with her and her daughter and it was me and Joey and Ari
and we were barbecued.
We were way too high to be watching the Joan Rivers thing.
And,
um,
I was freaking out about our face and I was like looking at this weird frozen
Kabuki mask thing that is her,
her field of expression.
You know,
it was just very bizarre.
Like everything was like pushed up and filled in frozen.
It just wasn't moving right.
And it was like,
oh my God,
like you're,
it's way better to be old than to be that.
Well,
I,
I can test that in the sense that people want to do things to make themselves
feel better.
And sometimes they feel if they look better,
they're gonna feel better.
Nobody questioned somebody when they comb their hair or brush their hair or wear
contacts instead of glasses or shave their beard.
You know,
those,
those are things that,
you know,
could be considered a selfish and vain,
but even your beard,
while,
I mean,
you know,
like trimming it.
I mean,
um,
you know,
and some people will go to extra extremes and want to put stuff in their face
and it makes them feel better.
Um,
I agree with you.
It could look kind of strange,
but if it makes them feel better,
hey,
I,
you know,
free will.
Well,
it's nice to feel better.
That's true.
But when you see someone and their face is no longer a human face,
it's like a weird mask,
a frozen mask that doesn't communicate right.
It's just,
it gives us,
it gives you a creepy feeling.
Like,
is it,
it can,
the signals are all wrong.
I'll give you talk to someone and you talk to like a really old person and
there's lines all over their face and you're talking to them.
You realize,
wow,
this guy has lived 90 years,
90 years on this planet.
Like you could see it in his face,
but if you talk to that same guy and he's just frozen mask with silicone on his
lips,
everything like it's fucking strange because you're not,
you're not getting in there,
you're not seeing it.
It's like,
it's like you're talking to him through a really thickly tinted window.
Like I could see there's a person in there and they're talking to me,
but I don't,
I'm not exactly sure what kind of expressions they're making.
You know that you know that weird.
There's a weird thing that people do when they shut off the expressions of their
face.
It doesn't,
it can't talk and moving around anymore.
You see someone,
they,
I'm like,
they're super well,
he's honest.
Is He fucked up his face and his face looks pretty,
worked on really well.
Maybe he's a old,
I mean it's not that.
I don't know.
He doesn't,
he doesn't.
Joan Rivers it.
Did you hear the,
the thing recently,
like uh,
this is like a day before the Oscars that uh,
he got,
he was at a gym at three in the morning and Hollywood and this guy was working
out and then to full just comes up and just like introduce us like,
hey,
how's it going?
And John,
how's it gone?
It wasn't the week before how it was a long time ago.
Oh,
it was?
Yeah.
It was a store that went around.
It was like a non story.
It's like,
what did he do?
He said hi to a guy in the morning so we'll knows what he really did.
That guy,
it's,
we're taking that guy's word for it.
He's probably trying to get his dick sucked.
You're right.
Probably it's probably what he does,
you know,
three o'clock in the morning.
You never know.
Maybe it's like rest stops.
Like that's where gay dudes meet to try to hook it.
Equinox.
Yeah.
You never know.
But so is that what the gist of the story was?
They were trying to hit on a guy and I said that it was really awkward because
at three in the morning this guys comes up to him and he like holds out his hand
and starts like introducing himself.
And the guy was like,
you know,
I felt when he was doing,
but I was,
well,
I read the story was,
I mean the guy was just saying that it was odd to talk to Jonathan,
but it's a non story.
The Guy said there was a guy said hi.
I mean it could be you.
Yeah.
Brian redband came into the fucking equinox,
three o'clock in the morning.
It was,
we're out to me.
And real strange,
you know.
Okay,
let's print a story.
Imagine if there's was a story.
It became a story.
Every time you said hi to someone at the gym.
You know what it is?
Every celebrity encounter is a story.
Not necessarily something that you know,
gets into the media.
But I remember living in New York and taking a train out to,
uh,
chuckles and Mineola.
Yeah.
And they put you in a place where they put you in a cab.
You know,
it's like five people have to share a cab from the train station to the town.
So there's three people I guess.
So we're in the cab and the guy goes,
so where you had night?
And I said,
I'm going to chuckles.
And then,
oh,
you comedian.
Yeah.
You know,
you're gonna have that awkward conversation.
And so this cab driver says I had a rose,
um,
Roseanne Barr and the in the car.
And I remember driving by and she was looking out the window and she was
intrigued by a mailbox that she saw in front of one of the houses.
And you know,
so there's like a nothing story,
but I'm thinking Roseanne Barr doesn't remember the story,
but this guy,
that's his Rosanne.
Well Rosanne Arnold now,
but I mean that's his story.
So like if anybody gets into an elevator with a celebrity,
they,
they will tell that story for the rest of their life that the celebrity's not
going to remember that particular elevator ride.
But if you happen to be in an elevator one time in your life with Paul Newman,
anytime that's Paul Newman's mentioned your,
that's your story.
And it's weird that every,
every encounter is a story to somebody.
A story
that I talked about on the podcast because it in an elevator,
we,
me and my friend Eddie,
we're in an elevator and some guy was in the elevator and apparently when the
guy left the elevator,
he said,
take it easy or something like that.
And we didn't respond,
you know,
or if he did respond,
he didn't hear me.
I don't know what happened,
but he wrote this long crazy post on this message board about what a Douche bag
I am,
Dan.
I mean,
I literally,
I mean it was like,
Hey,
what's up?
So getting the elevator and the guy left and uh,
you know,
and I thought that was it.
There was a guy in an elevator and that's it.
But in his mind he was slighted like in some strange way,
which is if someone says hi to me,
I always say hi,
I'm,
I'm not the type of person that says take it easy.
I'll say,
yeah,
take it easy.
You know,
always,
always trying to be cordial.
I'm just not that guy.
Right.
So reading that this like artificial creation in this guy's mind,
like any apologize for it.
Then it got really weird like,
you know,
like people,
he got called out on it and so that you,
you responded in a way and then he,
and then he dies.
But it was a message board that I go to.
So it was like,
it's really strange.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
And so then he backed off of it and apologized and said he was just insecure.
It was like,
it was very,
very,
very fucking strange.
But to see someone just create this artificial version of an encounter and in
their mind,
I mean his mind,
who knows?
I mean I don't know what issues this guy had.
Obviously he has some,
otherwise he wouldn't have ever made a post like that.
Even if you had slighted him.
Why is that?
W W w what's the big deal to him and the rest of his existence?
And if it was a satellite,
I mean,
I mean it wasn't,
but in his version of a slight,
it was as minor as it gets.
Yeah,
like take it easy.
No one says anything back.
That's it.
And this fucking diatribe,
I mean several paragraphs of bile like spewed by this guy,
but in some people's minds,
like these encounters like you talking to Roseanne Barr about a fucking mailbox,
like it's sedan.
Roseanne Barr Shits on people's mailboxes.
Like what kind of mailbox you got ballet,
are you fucking cunt?
Like full whatever.
What kinds of strange mailbox?
Maybe she's just trying to make small talk.
You fucking know.
He wasn't saying it negatively was just saying that that was what his encounter
was.
So that was his story.
But it could be negative.
I mean there's a lot of those.
I've had conversations with people.
I always get in when I get in Limos,
I always ask,
who's the biggest shit?
Had you ever had to drive around a few people where we've done that a bunch of
times and we hear that,
hmm.
Can't believe it's him again,
can fire.
Yeah.
There's definitely that.
Everybody,
everybody should get one pass.
You know what I mean?
Like everybody's going to have a bad thing or something that's confused,
but if it's a recurring thing,
then there's probably some truth to it.
Absolutely.
That wasn't an elevator one time with a guy and he recognized me as a comedian
and he wanted to do one of my bits to me,
but he got it wrong.
And the bit was just old bid.
I used to do about saying youtube at the wrong time,
getting out of a cab
at the airport and the driver goes,
have a nice flight and you go,
you toe.
So,
so that's the bit,
so I'm in the elevator with them,
this guy,
and he goes,
oh,
you're not a comedian,
right?
And said,
yeah,
yeah.
How are you doing?
You know,
when he goes,
you're the guide,
it says,
and you all the time.
So I'm not going to call him out on it.
I'm honored,
even knows who I am,
so I'm not going to embarrass him.
I said,
yeah,
that's me.
That's me.
And he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
I do not all the time.
I'm always saying,
and you at the wrong time.
And now I'm like,
no,
I shouldn't.
I should have.
Correct.
Did
you know what I mean?
And he goes,
yeah,
there's probably not a day goes by that I don't know.
And,
and you,
and I'm thinking this is getting off the tracks.
So the elevator door opens,
it's in a casino with a bunch of people and we walk off the elevator,
I'm going one way and he goes the other way.
So he starts yelling to me thinking,
it's going to be funny.
What he thinks is my bit in a casino now with hundreds of people and he's going
and Yo and Yo,
oh God.
And I'm thinking,
I'm the only guy here who knows what this guy's talking about and I don't know
what he's talking about.
It was very,
very straight.
You could run into people,
man,
and just use zig when you should have zagged,
and you run into someone who's completely out of their fucking mind and then
they become a part of your life.
I mean,
that can happen.
You could definitely run into the wrong people,
especially if a girl,
especially if you're single,
he just,
for whatever reason,
start talking to someone and it turns out that they're fucking crazy.
And then you,
you know,
that's a problem with men.
Men are willing to,
we're willing to look past a lot of shit if a chick's hot.
I'm like,
I know a lot of guys that have got involved with girls that are just completely
out of their fucking mind,
but they're pretty,
and they're just like,
oh,
you know,
she's a little weird,
but not,
no,
no.
She was a guy.
It would be running from her.
And you imagine if that was a gal and would she be,
she had giant tits.
Yeah,
I'd be running back to answer.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's me.
I'm that guy.
Hey Man,
let's do it up.
You'd take it to a restaurant.
She's yelling out and you,
and you then when she sees your act and then like she sees an old recording and
she sees that bitch,
he goes,
oh fuck.
Tell me you had me making an asshole.
You fucking selfish BZ shit.
Brian,
are you doing it like during the wedding vows?
And she says,
Hey,
and you,
and you go,
all right,
I gotta tell Ya.
Oh,
people that you meet in this wacky life,
I've got to think the people you meet living in Vegas is a,
well,
you're in Henderson,
right?
I don't want to tell you where you're not too late.
I'm not,
I'm not there.
Beautiful.
You're in one of those suburban towns outside of the Vegas and uh,
you're actually further than that.
You were like deep in the woods in the secret underground compound.
It's can't discuss.
But the point being that like,
you're,
you're in a real
normal town that just happens to be next to the death star.
Like you're like,
you're like in the vicinity of the death star.
Like you could probably drive,
you can get to the strip in a reasonable amount of time,
but the people that you live with,
they like affected at all by the fact that they live in Vegas or do they seem
like regular folks in a regular town?
Well,
I used to live in a house in a cul de sac and so there was more interaction with
the neighbors and now I live in one of those,
uh,
you know,
condo kind of deal.
So I now I have less interaction with the other people in the Condo,
but in the cul de sac,
you know,
um,
one thing I liked the things I liked about it and didn't like about the neighbor
thing.
One,
I'm not a kind of guy that just wants to have a conversation when somebody else
feels like having a conversation.
I just felt weird about pulling up into the driveway and then Joe blow wants to
just walk up and to start talking about the water pump or something that has to
do with the Culdesac or even small talk.
It's like,
well,
I don't want to do that right now.
But one thing I did like about it is because it,
it was so non show busy and I've got a lot of friends in show business and I
love him and of course they're going to be interested in their careers and
that's what people are going to tend to talk about.
When I lived in La,
there was just a disproportionate amount of conversations about auditions that
people went to and what they're up for and how they feel about an agent or this
or that.
And that's okay.
But it's nice to be away from that.
And one thing I loved about this just very suburban kind of cold,
the sac and Las Vegas was,
you know,
I'd come back from the road,
right?
So I'm just,
I'm doing comedy and I'm doing show business and I come back from the road and
there's neighbor kids riding their bikes in the cul de sac and the dad's saying,
yeah,
I put her bike together yesterday and it's just very real.
And I liked,
I liked having this show Biz life balanced with the real grounded kind of world.
We're not,
everything is about,
you know,
furthering careers and stuff.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a big thing that a lot of people experience about any sort of environment
like Hollywood where it's just so based on one industry and he just gets so
wrapped up in that world that it's exhausting.
I,
when I was living in Las Vegas,
I've been in Las Vegas over 10 years now and uh,
I was out here doing something and I met a guy on the street.
I didn't know who he was,
but he was a comedian and said,
uh,
hey man,
he knew who I was.
And um,
so I said,
hey,
how's it going?
And he said,
well,
I've got an audition for this.
I got it.
And he started telling me things.
He,
he was up to Showbiz wise.
And I'm thinking,
that's not what I meant by how are you dealing,
right.
I meant like,
you know,
how are things that you feel like there's a guy that I won't name but I can't
talk to them anymore because every time I talked to him that happens.
I ran into him.
We were both working in the same venue.
Uh,
he was doing the really show.
I was doing late show and uh,
I ran
into him and I said,
hey man,
what's up?
Well,
I've got a Bolo,
blah,
deal with a bubble.
I mean,
it just starts reading a resume.
He starts reading off this deal that he's gone,
his backup deal that he's got and his,
I mean,
he went on for several minutes.
It was fucking exhausting and I went,
good to see you're doing well.
Yeah,
well I took a deep breath and I looked like,
I don't know what to say.
Like I was stuck in this fucking hallway talking to this guy.
There was no way to get out.
It was no one there,
but me and him and he just rattles off this fucking crazy resume.
A bullshit.
Just nonsense.
That by the way,
never happened.
None of it happened.
I mean,
here we are years later and none of those things took place.
But he was telling me they didn't have backup deal and this sitcom,
if this didn't go,
he has a backup deal.
They're going to pay him.
Some mom,
mom,
mom.
It was just nonsense.
Just,
but that happens.
Never had a backup deal,
man.
I don't want to,
I don't want to get where I'm,
I'm,
I'm in that place where I have a deal and a backup deal.
Yeah.
I guess I have a deal.
I don't even think he had a backup too.
I think he's just a,
I don't even think he's a bullshit artist.
I think,
you know,
it's just what he wanted,
what he wanted.
So he's just like telling me that he's doing great.
There's some people they run into you,
you know,
you run into a certain guys and you want to prove to them that you're doing
well.
You know,
like they maybe have some weird thing about them.
Like they go,
oh,
this ties doing better than me.
I'm going to tell him I'm doing awesome.
I'm going to let him know right away that we on even ground.
So that's where this,
you know,
if he was running into some open Miker,
and say,
hey man,
how you doing?
He'd be like,
yeah,
good.
How are you doing?
Like that would be normal because he would already feel like he has the
advantage.
Right.
And I know I'm guilty of having,
I don't,
I don't know.
There are times when I think,
you know,
I have the proper amount of just low key thing,
but I know there's a little piece of me,
that little ego part of me that that needs to participate,
you know,
it,
it like comes out of me sometimes if like if somebody has the wrong idea of
maybe what I've been able to do as a comedian.
Right.
You know,
like you meet somebody at a party or something and,
and I,
I'll never say what I do unless him point blank asked and I'll go,
what do you do?
And so then now I'm going to be honest as I'm a comedian and,
and they go,
oh you do like open mic nights and stuff like that.
Is that what you do?
And then that little ego part of me is like,
now how do I,
how do I reply to this?
Yeah.
This guy,
this person has the wrong idea of where I,
what I do,
you know,
or where I'm at.
But you can't be braggy,
but you don't want to be braggy,
you know?
So,
so what at what level do you answer a question like that?
You know,
just like,
do I,
do I just say no,
I don't do open Mike Nights and let it go with that or do I,
you know,
throw something out there that
I used to,
you could say,
maybe I used to do open Mike Nights.
There you go.
Yeah.
I had this guy running.
I ran into this guy at a fucking gun store for,
you know,
at all places.
And,
um,
the first words that I said,
this guy never met him before.
First words,
he goes,
Hey,
uh,
you're,
you're Joe Rogan,
right?
I go,
yeah.
He goes,
how's your career doing?
That's his first words.
I go,
I goes,
good.
He goes,
you're not doing that fear factor Shell,
Huh?
Like,
puts them in a defensive.
I go,
nope.
And he goes,
top business,
good luck.
I'm like,
whoa.
Like,
but it was so douchey the way he was doing it.
It was so douchey.
But those are the only words I said.
I'm like,
all right.
I like,
like literally it ended right there.
I was,
I was high.
I was under the influence of the sacred plant at the time,
but it allowed me to relax more.
But it was like I wasn't going to get in an argument with the guy about it or,
or correct him,
but it was taken a back by how has your career,
well,
are the first words out of his mouth.
You could have said,
well you just said my name.
Yeah.
So obviously you know who I am,
but he's trying to paint me as a has been.
There's people that will do that to you.
They try to paint you as a has been,
hey,
you should like a guy did it to me at cvs once.
A guy that it's working behind the counter at cvs is this guys,
I don't know what country he's from,
but he's super,
he doesn't work there anymore,
but he was like super like agro.
He's like this,
this fucking face like,
and he goes,
hey,
you don't have that show anymore?
Like that's the words he said.
Wow.
And I go,
what?
You know,
I'm like,
if you don't have that show anymore,
Huh?
And I go,
no,
I don't have that show anymore.
I also don't work at CVS.
I fucking idiot.
Like,
what are you talking to?
I can leave anytime I want motherfucker.
You got to stay until your shifts over.
I had a what a Dick.
Like how much could you possibly make it CBS that you want to get shitty with
someone who comes in that used to be on a TV show?
Like he just,
the way he was saying it was just trying to put me on the defensive,
like make me feel bad,
but could,
he didn't,
but he didn't think it out much like you probably didn't think his life out,
which is why he was the fucking late night guy at cvs workers because a lot of,
uh,
I'm fortunate in that my,
the people that come out to see my show,
they're,
they're pretty cool people,
man.
You know,
I like meeting them after the show and they're nice people,
you know,
so I have no complaints there,
but every once in a while you're going to get a curve ball.
And I was working at,
uh,
the Improv down in Irvine and I remember I had a pretty strong set,
felt pretty good.
I walked off stage and this guy like walks like just beelined it back to me who
was in the middle of the audience.
And I felt okay,
I just,
I just made people laugh for an hour,
you know,
it felt like I did my job and he goes,
hey,
didn't I see you bomb on our scenario?
Like 10 years ago?
I was just like,
um,
yeah.
Yeah.
I had a rough one.
Did you see tonight show
we're in the middle of tonight.
I just did an hour tonight.
We're not talking about that.
We're talking about 10 years ago.
Yeah.
The people want to make you feel bad,
rough,
set,
pause.
People see you,
you know,
like,
oh,
this guy thinks he's something special.
I'm going to let him know I'm going to knock him down a peg.
I saw money wasn't at its best psalm in that weird environment of the,
those shows doing stand up on one of those fucking shows is so brutal.
It's so hard to,
first of all,
um,
I don't know,
like if you feel comfortable doing like a real short set,
but I always feel real weird when I would do five minutes,
like five minutes.
To me it's like I don't,
that's,
I have long bits,
like five minutes.
To me it's just exploring a premise.
It's a whole different animal.
I,
you know,
uh,
I like the challenge of it,
but it's,
it's so different from doing an hour set,
especially in our set in front of people who,
you know,
are,
they're there to see what you do.
Yeah.
Um,
but if I do Letterman or something like that,
I'm walking out to a group of people who have no clue who I am.
Maybe a handful of people in the audience too.
But for the most part it's like,
you know,
here's a comedian and a,
you're walking out and on Letterman you get four and a half minutes and uh,
you know,
it,
it's a very,
very challenging thing to yeah.
I describe it to people as people think of comedy as knocking down the pins.
Well the hard part is setting up the pins.
There's no pin set up.
You're walking out to nothing,
walking out to nothing and you have to set up pins quickly and then knock them
down.
Yeah.
And people don't realize that that's part of the art form.
And part of the challenge,
um,
is coming out to nothing.
It's white.
So Virgin Snow and you have to quickly talk about something and set up something
and then start getting people into that.
And it's a lot more challenging than people might think.
It's one of the harder jobs in as far as standup goes is doing a talk show set.
It's one of them harder gigs.
It's like opening up because like when you,
when you go on stage cold and there's no one who warms up the crowd before you,
you have to get everybody into the mindset.
There's like,
there's a thing going on.
The way I describe it is it's like almost like a mass hypnosis.
Like when I'm watching a Brian Regan show,
when you're killing,
I'm thinking the way you're thinking.
I'm not thinking in my mind like,
man,
he's doing,
like if I was in my own head,
I was like,
man,
I don't like the way he dresses.
This guy's fucking walks weird.
Do you know what I mean?
Like if you have like date,
you're going to get out of that the mindset,
right?
When when a guy's killing,
when you're up there and you're letting it loose and everything's flowing,
I'm thinking like you,
I'm allowing you to sort of control where my thoughts go and you're surprising
me with your statements.
And those surprises are often really funny and that's how you kind of get comedy
going.
But when you're just
starting out like ready go and you're doing four minutes,
you don't get a chance to hypnotize anybody.
You just kinda got to hope that they're kind and they're receptive and then
they,
they think that your first few words are reasonable enough to allow you a
certain amount of access to their,
their,
their funny thought.
I remember somebody years ago,
and I wish I could remember who it was,
this was before I had ever done a TV set,
say that you have to get it into your head that the first joke is going to be a
foul ball and don't let it throw you because you're not going to get the
reaction that you get in front of your fans,
your first set and a TV,
your first joke and a TV audience,
they don't know you.
They're,
they'll go,
who is this guy?
You know,
they're usually trying to be friendly.
They,
they want to like you.
So your first joke is there absolute first clue of how you think as a comedian.
So they're not going to be all in yet.
So it's,
it might get a laugh,
but it might not get the laugh that you're used to it getting,
but you have to understand that and go,
I know this first one is a foul ball.
It's just going to go off and if it does get a bigger laugh,
okay,
that's a bonus.
Now I can ride it.
But I think it's best to go out there assuming that it might get nothing or,
or a little laugh because if you go out there thinking this is going to kill and
it doesn't,
it could throw you for the whole set.
Yeah,
I've seen that.
I've seen that in regular shows.
I've seen guys go out there that never have opened up before or haven't done in
a long time,
and they'll go out and try to rush it.
They'll try to rush the first joke like before,
like settle down folks,
what's up?
How's everybody doing?
Thanks for coming out tonight.
They just immediately go into a bet,
right?
When you immediately go into a bit and it doesn't work,
then you're like undefensive motor tailspin mode and you're trying to cover.
I,
I've,
you know,
I'm,
it's a constant quest to try to figure out how to learn how to do comedy both in
front of fans or in front of TV audiences and stuff like that.
And that's one thing I love about it is that you're always learning.
You're always learning.
Sometimes you can prepare too much,
sometimes you can prepare too little.
It's like a,
it's a never ending process.
I think it would be a mistake to get to the point where we go,
oh,
okay,
I got this figured out.
Yeah.
I don't ever want to feel like that.
I want to feel like I'm learning every time I hit the stage.
And,
um,
that's one of those things that's a blast about doing like a,
a TV set.
You know,
I,
I've kind of learned over the years after the foul ball,
it's,
uh,
it's animals,
man.
It's like you have to let that audience,
no,
you are comfortable.
You got to let them know,
smell your weakness.
Gas,
you've got to let them know I got this.
And um,
and it's a cool feeling because that's the moment where you're either going to
go south or you're going to get them.
You know what I mean?
And,
uh,
it's a fun,
I dunno.
It's fun.
It's,
it's like hunting,
I guess.
You know what I mean?
No,
I love it.
I love it too.
The same for the same reason because it's,
it's constantly challenging.
Yeah.
You never know.
You never have it down.
You just don't,
you know,
you have it good enough and he can go out there.
Like,
I'm confident.
Like I did some shows this weekend in Portland.
Every show was fucking amazing.
Great crowd had a great time.
But before every show,
I'm going over my notes,
I'm thinking about what bits I want to do.
I'm tweaking this and tweaking that and I'm getting in the ring.
You can't,
you can't disrespect it.
You know,
you can't ever get cocky.
You can't ever think that,
you know,
for whatever reason that there's the learning processes over,
it's never over.
Especially when you're constantly creating new material,
then it's really never over.
Like I did a special November,
abandoned all the material once it was done,
once it was on TV,
I'm done.
Now I have a whole new fucking hour I have to hone and sharpen and add to.
And that's always terrifying.
It's always terrifying when you trying out new shit and adding new shit to it
and tweaking it and changing it.
But that's what's exciting about it.
That's what's so fun about it.
It's so fun that you've got all this new stuff that's in your head and it's like
the saddest thing about comedy is watching those guys that have been doing
comedy forever,
that do the same jokes they did 20 years ago.
That's one of the saddest things you could ever say.
Yeah.
I,
um,
I work with a guy one time and he had a bit and uh,
it was a pretty good bit and I remember thinking,
oh,
that's a good idea.
And He needs to,
you know,
work on that,
tighten it up and then get to that point a little bit quicker or whatever.
And then I worked with a guy like two years later and he did the same joke word
for word,
like no tightening of the screws at all.
And I remember kind of being disappointed.
I like as a fellow comedian saying,
well,
I mean I didn't say that to him,
but thinking,
yeah,
why aren't you working on this?
You know?
Well,
it's delusional.
He's delusional.
He's either delusional or he's lazy.
Those are the
two options,
right?
It's like you're delusional.
You think it's good enough and you don't have to change it or you're lazy and
that you don't want to work.
You know,
you don't want to fuck with it.
You don't want to tweak it.
You have to.
There's no way you get,
good.
Years ago,
I started at the Comic Strip in Fort Lauderdale and a Rodney Dangerfield was
performing at the sunrise musical theater and he came into the comic strip to do
a guest set,
like warming up for the,
his big thing,
you know,
down down the road.
So of course,
a small comedy club in Fort Lauderdale,
we're honored to have him.
He goes on stage,
crowd goes nuts.
You know,
it's a small audience,
you know,
200 people or whatever.
He's like,
Hey,
you know,
thanks for,
I want to work some stuff out.
You know,
I appreciate it.
he takes his glasses out and I'd been doing comedy like six months at this
point.
You know,
I worked there as a bus boy and they let me go on late at night and I hear,
I get to watch Rodney Dangerfield.
He,
he goes on stage,
he tells the audience that he wants to work on some jokes,
he takes glasses,
reading glasses out.
He takes that about 20 little three by five cards and he reads him half
performing them,
half reading them,
you know,
going to,
I just want to get a feel for these things,
you know,
and,
and he,
and he does them in some laugh,
some,
some work,
some don't work.
And then he leaves and I'm like,
wow,
that was interesting.
You know,
he's working on is working on his act.
I'd never seen a star comedian work on his act.
He came in the next night and said,
hey,
you know,
can I do a guest set?
Of course he goes on now there's no glasses,
there's no three by five cards of the 20 jokes he's doing about eight of them
and they're tighter versions of what he had done the night before.
And it,
I'm getting goosebumps just thinking about it.
It's like when it dawned on me,
this is a,
this is an art form.
This is a craft and you can work at this.
You can some,
any,
anybody could watch Rodney Dangerfield end result and just laugh.
Go.
That was fun.
But I got to watch him.
I got to watch,
figure this out,
take stuff,
trim out fat and figured out how to make a set.
And like from that moment on I realized,
you know,
just go on stage and then go home and just chill.
You know,
you,
you work on it and,
and so I love the process.
I love the offstage process.
I love working on jokes,
man.
Making them 1% better.
That's always my philosophy.
I just,
if I can change one word and make that joke 1% better,
why not?
Yeah.
Or Cut,
cut words out and get to a quicker,
I knew it has more impact.
Right.
And,
and that doesn't mean that every joke needs,
you know,
some jokes.
Yeah,
it's better to stretch something out if it's a free or form kind of thing.
To me it's like an accordion,
you know,
some stuff you're,
you're pulling out and other stuff you're squeezed and all that stuff is
happening simultaneously.
Or like maybe music where sometimes you have this like really slow buildup and
sometimes it's like really fast.
Really,
really loud.
It all varies and it all depends on the subject matter.
It depends on you,
the what you're trying to do and what,
what that bit leads into when you write.
Do you write on paper,
do you write on a computer,
do you write like do you sit down and say,
I'm going to write jokes today or do you just have an idea and just start
writing about it?
I,
I don't know how to sit down in front of a blank piece of paper or a blank
computer screen and come up with stuff.
I don't know how to do that,
you know?
Um,
the original inspiration has to be external.
You know,
I just have to experience something or see something or read something.
I,
so I just go through my normal day or life the way I normally would and things
jump up and down.
It's like a kid in gym class,
you know,
pick me to be on the basketball team.
Something in life jumps up and down and you go,
oh,
that's weird.
And then you have your initial weird comedic view of it.
So the inspiration comes from an external source.
And then all right,
now I have the nucleus,
then I can,
right.
Then it's like,
okay,
now I know,
I know what the thought is,
the idea now what words am I going to apply to it to,
to get from beginning to middle to end.
And then that part will could take a year or longer.
You know,
going on every night and changing the world's changing it,
you tightening it,
switching it,
you know like that.
And you
don't go necessarily to comedy clubs to work out.
You kind of work out your bits in between like bits that are already
established.
Yeah.
Cause most of the time you're doing these big theaters and your,
your,
your tour de tour like four or five days in a row or do you just do weekends?
Like how do you set it up?
I do two weekends a month and those weekends are for one nighters.
I do Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
Oh you will be only do two a month.
Do you do every other or do you do two in a row?
It's,
well it depends.
I work half the weekends of the year.
And you do this so that you can hang out with your kids and spend time.
Yeah.
That's cool.
And when you do it,
do you like you purposely say like,
okay,
I've got,
you know,
a bunch of bits I'm going to do in the beginning that I know are rock solid.
I get everybody rocking and then I'll slide this new stuff in there and see how
it works.
I try not,
I don't want to have that overly figured out either.
You know,
it's like,
um,
you know,
I,
I want to,
I don't want to lose that weirdness of hitting something right off the bat that,
I dunno if it's gonna work or not.
You know,
it's,
it's a temptation to go to a surefire laugh and I usually do,
but every once in a while I'll say to myself,
I need to go out and do something relatively new that I've never opened with.
Um,
and,
and see how it flies because I want to keep exercising every muscle.
You know?
I mean,
there's a lot of guys out there who just always open with the same thing and
always close with the same thing and it's like,
I don't,
I want to keep switching that up.
You know,
you are also in this place where you're doing these big crowds and you don't do
other stuff.
Like,
you're not doing a lot of television shows as far as like sitcoms or you're not
doing a lot of movies.
You're doing a lot of these things.
So it's like you're constantly performing,
you're constantly performing,
you're constantly adding to,
this is sort of,
uh,
this,
this database of jokes and material,
you know.
Yeah.
I like what you're doing,
man.
I think it's really cool cause you were,
you were like trying to do the Sitcom thing for a while,
like everybody else and then you just like,
well fuck this.
Just do substantiate it.
I,
you know,
I mean heck,
you can't argue with somebody getting a Sitcom and then,
you know,
the being able to be set for life or whatever.
And um,
and I,
but,
but I have always liked to stand up and I always thought you needed to get a
sitcom to get to the point where you could play in theaters.
Right?
So that was why I wanted a sitcom so that I could get my exposure up to then I
could continue doing standup.
But now in front of fans,
we thought that in the 90s everybody thought that and I didn't realize,
well,
I kind of got there without having to do that.
You know,
it's like,
wow,
I'm building the following just from the standup [inaudible] standup thing,
just kept kind of getting bigger and bigger and bigger.
And so I was able to make that jump from comedy clubs and theaters and uh,
so now,
you know,
I'd still,
I'd be lying if I said I wouldn't want to do a TV thing,
but I would,
I would want it to be around my creative vision and I'm not interested in being
a star.
I'm interested in my comedy being a star.
Right.
Well that's one of the cool things about what you've been able to achieve when
you do these really big places,
but you're in is reasonable celebrity mode where it's very reasonable.
You're like,
I've,
I've hung out with you.
You could walk around the casinos and occasionally people will recognize you and
every line of that,
but it's not in weird,
you know,
you don't have to hide.
You're not getting overwhelmed.
You don't get chase.
And Hog,
but your pack and these giant fucking places like you have these fans,
it's like you just hardcore group of dedicated fans,
they will come to see you because you've earned them by traveling over and over
again back and forth to the same spots and packing these same places.
It's a very unique thing you've done.
I,
it's a very bizarre situation because I dunno what the percentages are,
but,
but I truly feel like if you pulled a hundred Americans just at random,
I swear I think 98 of them and showed them a picture of me or something like
that,
98 of them would not know who I am,
maybe 99.
Um,
yet I do have enough people that will want to go to these venues.
I,
I'm not exaggerating when I say how strange it is for me to be in a theater.
Say there's 2000 people there and I do my show.
I could go a half a mile down the street to a burger king afterwards and walk in
and nobody in there knows who I am.
And I'm like,
how do these two disparate things,
how can I be big man on campus,
a half a mile that way.
And then here nobody knows,
nobody knows who I am while you've done it by establishing this like really
loyal fan base you ever,
it's very unique what you've done.
So the people that know you love you,
but you know,
maybe it's only 1% but if you look at that 1%,
if there's 350 million people,
that means 3.5 million people fucking love you.
I'm not,
I'm not bothered by,
I like it.
In fact I,
I'm not saying that you are,
but I'm saying that's,
it's a very unique,
I it,
and I realize too that anonymity is a commodity.
You know,
there are,
there are celebrities who probably might not want to be as famous as they are in
terms of just being able to go out and having a meal or something like that.
And it's like,
you know,
I don't have that issue,
man.
Yeah.
So I,
I have,
I have this career in show business with the following and nobody knows who I
am.
And you kind of,
if people can do that,
you kind of engineered it to,
I mean,
I remember when you first started like really going on the road hard and you
started moving from clubs to theaters.
It was all based on repeat customers.
It's all based on people going to see you really loving your material,
really laughing,
having a great time,
and then said,
oh,
Brian Regan's back in town.
And then boom,
boom,
boom.
Then it slowly started building up and then I,
you know,
I'd heard,
I mean,
I don't know how many years ago you started like packing these large theaters,
but I'm like,
I kept hearing like,
dude,
Brian Regan,
it's just fucking killing it on the road.
The difference being that if you had a sitcom,
like maybe you would get people to come see you,
but you would not have nearly as much time to perform and to work on your
material and your sets probably wouldn't be the same.
It probably wouldn't have the same level of competency on stage that you do now
because you know you've been hammering that Samurai sword for fucking,
you know,
decades and bang,
Bang.
There's guys,
and I don't want to name any names,
but it's sad when you see a guy who took seven,
eight years off to do a successful Sitcom and then they start doing standup
again and you realize they got soft,
not just soft,
but it's atrophy.
Just the waste.
They just not did.
Not only did they not get better,
they got worse.
Whatever that muscle is that allows you to do comedy and hypnotize those 4,000
people in the theaters that you're performing and they don't have that muscle
anymore.
It's just not,
it doesn't exist anymore.
It's all just sort of like slipped away from them.
And there's like a ghost of what it used to be that they're trying to
reestablish these embers are trying to blow on and then,
you know,
add good analogy.
Yeah,
I mean that's really what it is.
I mean it's,
we were talked into believing that the only way to be successful as a comic,
it was to do it the way Roseann had done it or the way Seinfeld had done it is
take that stand up and use it to parlay it into a sitcom.
And there was nothing wrong with that.
I'm not,
you know,
that there's nothing wrong with the,
Gosh,
I applaud anybody that can get a network to want to build a show around them.
And you know,
if you can have some creative fun with it,
even better and you know,
make your,
make your money for the rest of your life and all that day.
You know,
I,
I don't denounce any of that,
but,
um,
you know,
I,
I like comedy as an end result.
You know,
some people want comp use standup comedy as a stepping stone to get to something
beyond that that they think is better.
And I'm like,
well,
I don't think there's anything better.
I like it,
you know?
Yeah.
We just talked into a long time ago.
Like I said,
especially in the 90s were talked into thinking that this is not it.
This is just it.
That gets you to something else because that's something else like a lot of
times a lot of fucking money,
like more money than you're ever making,
doing stand up at the time.
Like they put you on a sitcom.
Like w when I was on news radio I called the sudden I was on the Sitcom and that
was a great experience for me.
But this,
it's being on a great sitcom is even though it's a lot of money,
this is not nearly as much fun as doing stand up.
It just never will be.
It's just,
it's not.
It's also not nearly as much fun to watch.
Like if I had to choose between going to see you doing standup or watching you
in a sitcom,
there's no comparison.
Like,
and even though this stuff that you do especially like your,
your act as squeaky clean as one of the,
you're one of the rare guys.
It's universally like respected as being one of the most hilarious guys
out there as a standup comics.
But you're squeaky clean.
Like I could take my mom to see you and not feel weird.
I can take my daughter to see you and not feel weird.
Well thank you.
I did a show somewhere in this family came backstage,
including their a grandmother,
like this 80 year old woman.
And she said,
so how long have you been in Vaudeville?
Vaudeville,
Vaudeville?
Again,
I don't even know.
But you know,
like I guess I started around 1920 I don't,
I don't know.
Vaudeville's one of those expressions that I never really bothered to figure out
what it meant.
I Dunno.
So old kind of show Biz thing,
right?
Where there was a singer and a comedian and a magician or something.
I'm guessing.
I don't know.
Yeah,
more of a variety thing.
They used to have to do that.
Yeah.
Imagine if you had to do it.
Lenny Bruce Style and used to be the fucking,
I don't even see other night.
I don't know if I,
you know,
if I had to start,
like if I was born in 1930 or 40 and wanting to be a comedian,
I don't know if I would have made it.
I got fortunate in that when I want it to be a comedian,
there was a such thing as a comedy club where people are there to watch comedy
only.
Yeah.
And Open mic nights.
That's the big one is the open Mike nights like training wheels.
Like before open Mike dice,
like how the fuck did you ever get on stage the first time?
Right.
That's why a lot of those guys used to do joke jokes.
Like if you talked to like some of the old comics,
it'll be honest with you about like what was going on.
Like in the early days they would all share material,
you know,
they would all do jokes.
They would look like they would go to these places.
The people would never see them again,
you know?
And they would do a joke and then like their name would get out there that this
guy is hilarious and you'd go see them.
And they were like doing jokes,
like two guys walk into a bar.
Like literally they would do like street jokes.
Right.
And they would have a certain amount of them that they like.
Jackie the joke man Martley perfect example.
Jackie Martin Lane like literally knows every fucking joke that's ever,
he has a,
he has a segment that he does called stump the joke man.
Or He's doing radio where people would call him up with a joke and he would know
how the joke goes cause he literally knows every joke.
Yeah.
I've worked with him a number of times over the years.
And you know,
it's interesting the way he,
I mean I liked that there are different people doing different things and he's
like a joke joke guy.
It takes a lot of pride in that and that's fun to watch.
It's like,
okay,
that's,
that's what he's doing.
Yeah.
Joke,
joke.
Two guys walk into a bar kind of jokes.
Yeah.
Um,
but I also liked the fact that,
you know,
there's other people doing bizarrely are weirdly different kinds of comedy too.
You know,
that's what's so cool about comedies.
There's so many different things happening under that,
under that big umbrella.
You know,
one thing you don't see anymore,
prop acts,
carrot top killed the prop acts to so few prop backs.
It's weird.
When I was starting out there was a lot of pop acts like you go to open mic
night and on an average open Mike night,
maybe one guy would have prompts and you don't see them anymore.
Hmm.
Carrot,
top murdered.
That game is no more.
It's like don't like,
I like him.
He it,
when I used to work in Charlotte,
he used to live there and he would come out and he was always very uh,
cool and friendly and you know,
he was a college act at that time.
And you know,
I think he kind of knew the rap,
you know,
of how many people,
like what some people think about prop stuff.
But I dunno,
I,
I like to feel like,
hey man,
there's all different ways of doing comedy short.
You know,
it's funny.
Yeah,
he does.
He does props.
Great.
Yeah,
he's great at that.
And if you want to go there and just buy into that experience,
he's going to be holding things up and it's going to be silly and funny.
That's fine.
I think that's valid.
Oh yeah.
No,
I'm not criticizing it at all.
You know,
I don't have any problem with what he does.
And by all accounts,
he's a very nice guy.
But it's,
it's interesting that that genre,
it doesn't exist.
Anything that is interesting.
It's very few puppet acts.
He stays to [inaudible] very few puppet acts.
It's like a Jeff Dunham and those,
those whatever characters that he has,
he's kind of like nailed that down.
There's like a few guys,
like there's Terry fade or he does those impressions like he has that Terry Fade
or theater and uh,
at the Mirage.
But other than those two guys,
they used to be auto and George.
Did you ever get a chance to work with auto?
Yes,
I used to love watching George and he's my favorite of all time and when it
comes to puppet acts,
because he had a crazy rap,
like the puppet would say all the fucked up shit and then he would go,
uh,
I can't believe you're saying that.
Papago fuck you.
He got the puppy got stabbed once.
It's a legendary story.
Some guy that he was shitting on some guy in the audience and the guy jumped up
and stabbed the puppet like he has.
Give me the ultimate compliment.
My puppet.
I know I'm good at this.
I worked with them once and these kids were heckling.
We see your lips moving.
We see your lips will like that.
You Miss Missing the point.
Of course his lips are moving.
You think the dummies really fucking talking while you looking at his lips.
But you know,
people want like especially dumb people,
they want the ventriloquist to regarding wait weight total day.
I got news for you.
You can't,
you know,
they want your mouth to be completely still.
The one thing I never understood is people will say they can throw their voice.
What does that mean?
It means you're an idiot where it's hone it to really have the ability to have
your voice coming from another place outside of your mouth.
Your honor,
he threw his voice,
came out of the other person.
Did you throw your voice son?
Chase,
I remind you,
you are under oath.
You know this,
know this,
that that's a thing that people used to think people could do.
They used to think people could throw their voice.
I think as a kid I thought that that I would actually try like on the side of my
mouth,
but
no,
not over here.
I'm over here.
You could kind of like subtly make it seem like it's not coming from you.
Like maybe coming from this side of you,
you're blowed off the phone.
I hope there's not somebody out there who does that for a living and they feel
like I'm slamming him,
slamming his crap.
You like your support,
carrot copy on support.
Fuck
you ever watch a good comedy hypnotist?
Uh,
I,
yeah.
Yeah.
I,
I'm not big on the hypnosis thing because I,
you know,
um,
I think you can be really good at that.
I just,
I've,
maybe this is a very,
I dunno,
I don't believe that the people that are doing these things are really
hypnotized.
Wow.
Maybe I'm naive or I don't know.
You might use the wrong word.
You need to see someone who's really good at it.
There's people,
and I don't know why.
I don't know what it is.
I'm not saying there's that no one can be hit now.
I'm not saying there's people that no one can hypnotize because I've never tried
to be hypnotized.
I never sat down with a really good hypnotist and tried to be hypnotized.
I've,
I have friends that have,
and they swear by it and I know fighters that have done it and they say it helps
their,
their career and then helps their mindset.
But there are certain people for whatever reason,
that are really,
really susceptible to hypnosis.
And there was a guy named Frank Santos and he used to do this show back at
stitches in Boston.
And,
uh,
he would do it every week.
Frank Santos,
the r rated hypnotist.
And it was amazing.
I mean,
the staff would get their staff of the comic club comics who come down and watch
it because it was just the most bizarre thing.
You would see these people and they really believed what he was saying.
Like there'd be people that thought they were having sex,
they'd be people that thought they were naked.
But,
but how do you know that?
How do you know they believe that?
How do you know question?
How do you know that?
You know how Halloween,
isn't it fun to dress up like a vampire on Halloween because a,
it's okay to act crazy on Halloween night.
Maybe when you're going to one of these comedy hypnosis shows,
maybe you have the green light to act silly on stage.
You know,
it's like,
Oh wow,
I can do this and no one's going to hold,
hold me accountable to acting goofy on stage.
I can say I was hypnotized.
So maybe they just enjoy being in the limelight and acting goofy.
It is possible.
But there were people that he would tell them,
I'm going to say I'm going to count to three and when I count to three,
you're going to realize you're naked in front of all these people and you're
going to be terrified.
One,
two,
three and you'd see them like there would be two good.
There was some people that were just too good at acting like you would like.
They would be fucking confused.
They weren't hamming it up.
They weren't going over the top and he would talk to them and question them.
You don't have to see it man,
because he would also know when people weren't under.
He would know when people weren't under and we remove them from the stage.
He would know that they were faking and he'd look at them.
I think there's some people that are fucking stupid and they're open to
suggestion.
I will say this.
Th Th th th
I'll open the door to the possibility of hypnosis in the sense that you know how
like when you're watching a football game and all of a sudden the other team has
the ball and you're like,
I don't remember them punting yet.
I've been staring at this TV screen for five minutes.
Obviously my brain went somewhere.
I,
I missed the last few plays.
So maybe in life that can happen where somebody has the power to make your brain
go away for awhile.
I,
I don't know,
I used to think it was total bullshit until I watched this guy do it over and
over and over again week after week after week.
And then I became friends with them and talk to him and explained how he started
out as a,
he was hypnotizing people for like weight loss and quitting smoking and stuff
along those lines.
He just knew how to do it.
He just knew how to do it and he'd done it a long time and he knew when people
were under and when they weren't under.
I just think there's some,
I don't think you are,
but I think there's some people that are just really open to suggestion.
And I think there's also something that happens when you put them on stage
because I think people like they get really weirded out by the factor on stage.
The lights are on them and it makes them maybe,
perhaps some people even more vulnerable.
Right.
So I understand your a lack of belief,
the art form,
trying to be more open minded about everything.
So I will,
I will say that it is possible.
I wish there was a good one.
Yeah.
I would love to have like the best back.
Come here and try it on.
Maybe Jamie or somebody you want to see you for the comedy shows you what Jamie,
you want to see it live?
You really want to see it live.
I just wish there was more guys doing that.
I know his son,
Frank Santos junior does it now in New England,
but I,
uh,
I just wish there were more those comedy hypnotists out there.
Not that meant I did a show one time out in the road.
Uh,
like a fill in date and they didn't tell the the club I was filling in for a
comedy hypnotist.
Oh,
but they didn't even tell the audience.
Oh No.
And I had a bad set.
I get off stage and then I see table tents and all the tables,
you know,
comedy,
hypnosis night.
And people were coming up to me going,
how come you didn't make us act like chickens?
You know?
And I'm like,
that's when I found out you thought I was a comedy hypnotist.
I did an hour of total confusion for this audience.
So they're waiting to be hypnotized.
That's what they thought the show was.
That's hilarious.
So you're eating dick up there talking about socks and right.
And they're just waiting.
When is he going to start bringing us on stage?
Yeah,
they're just waiting.
If like you're warming them up for the comedy hypnosis thing.
And then I say good night.
And they were like,
what the hell?
You can just say you don't remember cause I hypnotized
and you pregnant and you were all feeling like you were naked.
Good eye.
How
weird.
That's what's the worst gig you ever had to do.
Do you have a worst?
Um,
I had one show where I walked almost the entire audience.
I filled in for a comedian and he called me up and said,
uh,
you know Adam Leslie?
No,
Adam Leslie,
he no longer with us,
but uh,
he had a headline Gig at some,
at a place called the comedy barn in Jackson,
Mississippi.
I think it was the,
the town down in the south.
He goes,
I can't do the date,
would you fill in and headline for me?
I was very new to headlining,
so I said sure.
And somehow the club was okay with him bringing somebody else in instead of him.
So I get onstage on a Friday night and just didn't get my foot in the door.
Um,
and just flatline and you know,
how you know how it is like you,
there's a point where,
you know,
this is over,
this thing happening.
And that was at that point that nothing,
no,
no savers,
we're working,
nothing was working.
And then a foursome at the front got up.
Like,
you know,
when I had like 30 minutes left and just put their coats on,
I mean,
how
put their jackets and stuff on it and just walked away.
So I'm thinking,
well,
maybe you know,
they have the babysitter or something and then another force him and then a
twosome and then everybody just thought,
well,
I guess it's okay to leave.
And everybody just got up and walked out.
I probably had 20 people left when I was done.
It was the most humiliating,
one of the most humiliating nights of my career.
How long ago was,
this is last week.
Leslie died.
I got a phone call from the book or
the book or killed him talking down to my club.
He murdered out money.
We're losing our mortgage now.
Yeah,
this was,
Gosh,
25 years ago.
I don't know those,
those moments when you're fucking tail spinning,
those are what some of the most painful and confusing moments in the comics
career.
But in my opinion,
those are like really important because they're all the big growth moments of my
early career came after I bombed,
bombed and then said,
okay,
I never want to fucking experience that again.
I got to figure out what did I do wrong?
Like why did I,
what did I opened with that sucked.
Did I not get them right off the bat did,
whereas was I not loose enough?
Was I not comfortable enough?
Was I not having enough fun?
Like what the hell was it?
What was I too cocky?
Was I too meek?
Like what,
what are the,
what's the,
what's the numbers?
You know,
you sometimes think it is to the audience completely.
The audience,
like just,
you know,
it's Friday night,
10 o'clock show.
These people are all just in a kind of,
uh,
the,
the audience can play a part in whether or not you have a good set or a great
set,
but the audience cannot play a part if you are,
if you're a really,
unless it's just the worst fucking horrendous group of fucking convicts.
Route on parole all on Beth.
It is possible,
but a lot of times have uh,
a bad audience,
but you could still get them and you'll have a good set.
You could still have a good set.
Sometimes you just go out there and it's magic.
Sometimes he'd go out there and you just feel so loose and the audience is so
ready right off the bat that everything is just flowing and amazing.
Like that was this weekend in Portland.
I did a helium,
that comedy club.
I'm trying to work on some new material.
I'm tightened things up so I like to go to comedy clubs.
When I do that,
I'd like to do a whole weekend at a comedy club.
You doing those two shows on Friday,
two shows on Saturday and it was just so fun.
It had been sold out for months.
It was like the oldest energy in the air and everything was great.
But then I did the comedy store like two Wednesdays ago.
Oh.
It was just like,
there was like no energy in the room.
Right.
Marin was on before me.
He was saying the same thing.
He got off stage.
I think he even said something like,
you guys,
uh,
you were there.
You know,
like,
I think you said that like saying good night.
It's just,
there was a weird lack of,
it was almost like one of these cross armed audiences where they're like,
they're not going to put out too much energy.
It's a Wednesday night at 10 30.
There's not much there,
but you still get them.
Like,
I had a good set.
It was still good.
It still went,
you know,
all the stuff that's funny.
Got Laughs.
I always,
I always felt like my job was to be one better than the audience that,
you know,
there are many comedians can do as well as the audience.
If it's a great crowd,
they do crate.
If it's a good crowd,
they do good.
If it's a bad crowd,
they do bad.
I always wanted to be one,
like I want it to be where like if they were bad,
I would do so.
So if they were so,
so I would do good.
If they were good,
I would do great.
And if they were great I would do great.
That's a beautiful philosophy.
So I just want it to one up,
you know what I mean?
Like it was my job to bring them to one higher level of what their situations.
I was at the Improv one night and it was a late show.
Uh,
it was like a 10:00 PM show on a Friday.
And,
uh,
the car,
the crowd was kind of tired and Brody Stevens went on and he was on like last
and he took his shirt off and started running through the crowd.
He made them play music.
He took his shirt off,
started running through the crowd,
and he was taking a shirt and spinning it over his head like a helicopter.
He's like,
we have energy and here are all la is happening.
This is real.
We're in Hollywood.
And he starts like clapping and putting his arms together and getting everybody
to clap along.
And he transformed the entire room and he went on stage,
transformed the,
I mean,
there's a video on my Instagram page of Brody.
It's late night pull,
pull it up,
the late night video of him drumming.
He does these closer spots at the,
uh,
at the comedy store where,
you know,
the show starts,
the main room show starts at nine o'clock and it goes on until two o'clock in
the morning and there's a point of no return.
There's a no man's land time somewhere after like 1130,
where the audience is like,
okay,
let's just get the fuck out of here.
I don't like a lot of people leave.
So it was packed.
And then when Brody goes on,
there's like maybe 25 or 30 peoples of this is,
this is,
this is a Brodie onstage playing drums.
Check this out.
Can we hear this through our headphones?
He's fucking playing drums.
I mean it doesn't even when he says he's got a guy next to the guy in the middle
aged guy back there,
the guy who his left that you can't see,
he's got thimbles.
Joe,
what does those things about?
Symbols.
Symbols,
right?
Tambourine.
He gave him a fucking tambourine,
the guy's got a tambourine and he gave it to the guy goes,
you back me up.
You've got the tambourine,
I mean I watched him for an hour and he went from that to doing stand up.
Well he's talking to the crowd.
He,
there was points in times where you see there's photo,
there's photos where you can see him walking around the crowd.
He put the microphone down and started doing standup.
Just walking around.
Yeah.
Friday nights.
Kennison spot in the main room is usually when Brody just does an hour,
he starts off the drums,
he rocks around.
It's great.
It's a great,
there's two guys that nail that spot.
Yeah.
Brian Holtzman and Brody Stevens cause they're both just freeform maniacs.
They just can just free ball.
And Brody especially because he does so many warmups.
He warms up for like sitcoms and talk shows and he's really good at it.
So they have him come in.
We had them do it when I did the man show.
He,
he's amazing at it.
Just creating comedy out of nowhere.
He just goes in there,
starts talking to people and the next thing you know,
I couldn't do that.
I don't have that ability.
I don't have that ability at all.
I've seen a couple of sitcoms,
tapings and watched the comedians that have to warm up that that is a skill that
is an amazing skill and I could not accomplish it.
It's an act.
It's a different kind of act.
It's,
it's like another facet of standup comedy.
I wouldn't say it's my favorite facet but don't,
but the thing about Brody is that that facet,
even though I don't necessarily like like watching warm ups that much,
right.
Brody has turned that into like approving or not approving ground but like a
training ground for him.
Like he's so comfortable just free balling about anything and everything and he
knows how to like hit it and turn it into comedy is a very unusual talent.
Brody Stevens and that he's really good at that.
That late night spot I've done since I've been back at the comedy store,
I've seen him do four or five of those late night spots are particularly just,
I just waited around and waited so I could watch Brody.
Michael Keaton was there last night by the way.
Was he reaching there,
Kimberly condom.
When the roast battle,
a academy award winner,
Michael Keaton movie won the Academy Award.
All right.
It sucks.
It's the worst movie.
I watched it three times.
Are you guys joking?
Jamie liked it.
You liked it?
I haven't seen it,
but I hear it.
I've heard quite a few people tell you is good.
You know what?
I'm going to have to watch it.
It was bothering me is there's all the,
there's this
video going around of Michael Keaton putting what some people are speculating is
an acceptance speech for best actor back into his pocket.
And the vibe is how embarrassing is that?
Why is that embarrassing?
You know,
that the guy,
the guy was up for the best actor at a point in his career where,
you know,
it's been a while since he's done anything.
I hate this negativity,
you know,
to to,
to take that moment and just blow that up as something that he should be ashamed
of or embarrassed.
Well,
so what,
he had an acceptance speech.
He was up for the Academy Award.
Didn't I see you bomb and Arsenio,
you,
hey,
how's your career?
I,
you know,
there's just,
I don't know,
there's too much.
There's too much,
uh,
unhappy people in this world don't,
I don't like to slam and people's dresses and all that stuff.
You know,
it's like they've been working their ass off or their career to finally get a
role where they're,
they're getting a little,
they're getting some attention and they get to go to this big Fun Academy Award
and they put everything they can into and putting this dress on and then some
guy or woman just gets to go,
I think it looks ugly.
Do you know why that exists?
Because of people like Kanye West because people that their egos are so blown
out of proportion.
You want to shoot them down.
They're so goofy.
So then you start looking at other people.
It was fun shooting him down.
Let me look around and see lots of fucking floss and then I don't like,
and you start looking for them.
It's like we don't like people that think they're better than everybody else and
one who when someone thinks they're better than everybody else,
they are a justifiable target.
So then it becomes like a genre,
like picking on people that are celebrities.
It becomes like a thing.
So then you start looking for all these other people that are successful and I'm
like,
wait,
and Michael Keaton,
but stupid fucking Yay Batman.
Oh I'm sorry you're not pat Barry anymore.
Is fucking movie won the Academy Award?
You can't.
But that's deaths people.
There's a lot of unbounced unhappy people and because of the Internet and people
making comments,
unfortunately,
you know,
it's like honking a car horn.
You can do it in the safety of your car cause you know,
it's unlikely that that guy's going to come over and actually have a physical
confrontation.
I think comments to me or Horn honkers they're,
they're just,
they're just people honk.
They're sitting in their underwear at home and they're just going to honk their
little horn there.
They didn't to throw their little negativity out there.
I don't know what they get out of it though.
I psychologically what?
What does that,
what do you get out of just typing some mean spirited bullcrap.
I don't get it.
They don't get anything out of it,
but they're not balanced people.
They're not thinking about what they get out of it.
They're not looking at their life objectively like what is the effort to reward
ratio to what I'm accomplishing here?
Or Am I accomplishing anything?
No,
they're just,
you know,
they go back to their shit back job on Monday morning,
some place that they hate where nobody likes them.
They go,
Ga seemed Michael Keaton,
how embarrassing thing back and pack I want to fuck her.
That's the world we live in.
And
it's also the world where people have a voice that never had a voice before.
You used to have to earn your voice.
You know,
if you were a great writer or a great critic,
you were respected by all these people that went and sought out your opinions on
things.
And so when they read your opinion on something,
it was like,
oh,
well this guy is a very thoughtful,
well measured person and his opinion on blank will be interesting to read right
now.
Everybody gets to put their opinion.
Everybody can have an opinion about everything.
I like it though.
I liked it cause I think it's ultimately balancing and I think that the cult of
personality that comes along with celebrity,
I think is ridiculous.
And I think this chips it down.
It brings it back down.
Look,
this is a weird time that we live in.
Is it a time where someone can hack in a Jennifer Lawrence his phone and find
pictures of her asshole and then put those on the Internet that never existed
before?
Well listen,
I,
I do understand that.
You know,
it's a different thing and yes,
now any Joe blow can have a comment.
I'm cool with that.
But I think there should be accountability.
I hate these trolls that hide behind fake names and they're negative and they're
not.
If you want to be negative or positive,
you,
you should own who you are.
Yeah.
It should be you,
you that that should be held accountable.
The person that you're slamming should be able to confront you.
I think they're,
well,
I don't know about that because you really want to confront everybody.
If you're a person that's in the public,
I you want to confront all those different people that can talk to you,
you'll waste your entire life dealing with,
no,
no.
I'm not saying that you need to confront people who are being negative,
but I'm saying that the person who wants to be negative out there,
it should be that person's name,
own,
own your negativity.
Well,
there's a little bit of that that's happening.
I mean that's a Facebook thing.
You know,
in,
in Facebook it's very difficult to have a fake name.
But I think that ultimately where this is leading is going to be,
there's a dissolving of all the boundaries between people.
People can reach you,
they can contact Brian Regan where they never could before.
People can reach you know someone and make fun of their celebrity speech there.
A acceptance speech.
People who can do things that you can get closer to you than they've ever been
able to do something before.
And I think ultimately the good thing about that is things like podcasts and
things like that that couldn't have existed before.
They,
they,
they take down this like boundary between people expressing themselves and then
expression being reached by other people.
You know,
if someone has really funny tweets,
they're really funny Twitter person that those really funny tweets can get
spread around and all of a sudden they have 100,000 followers.
There's a lot of people like that.
They're just regular folks or regular jobs,
but they're really funny.
And so this,
this,
just by quality,
just by people,
they're their ideas resonating with people.
They have a vehicle that never existed before,
so it doesn't always have to be negative.
I think it's just so many people are disenchanted and they just don't like life
and they're just depressed and they don't like their existence.
And so they're looking to like shit on people and spread negativity as much as
possible.
But what it shows is just that this vehicle exists and it doesn't just exist for
that exist for positivity.
That's true.
People aren't aware.
This is a new thing,
man.
This is something that we're navigating for the first time in human history.
And this is never existed before.
The ability to believe a youtube comment have the ability to have a,
a fake Twitter handle.
That's just an egg.
They can shit all over Brian Regan after a show.
Yeah.
You don't think hypnotizing these rail anyway,
I call,
how do you think I like fucking 50 pounds?
The question marketing,
I mean that's just,
that's it's,
it's a symptom of this new age that we live in,
that this,
this stage where technology as it's advancing,
it's advanced to this completely new realm that never existed before.
Where the ability to communicate with people is unprecedented.
The ability to reach people is unprecedented and we're navigating it.
We don't,
we don't know.
We don't know how to manage it yet,
and there's a lot of people that,
you know,
they're not thinking about what the impact of their words are.
They're just being idiots and they're,
you know,
they're not,
they're thoughtful.
They're not,
they're not really considering it.
This is a part of the weird world that we're living in the world of connectivity
and it's going to get crazier and crazier.
This is just one step.
This was one step.
There's going to be a time in the future where I believe we're going to be able
to communicate not just with words on a screen,
but with someone.
People are going to be able to express feelings to you.
They're gonna never be able to express emotions to you without even knowing you
and being around you and things are gonna get real weird over the next few
years.
Real weird.
They're not going to slow down.
They're going to speed up.
We're not going to move to log cabins and start chopping around firewood.
It's going to get weirder and weirder.
Goodnight everybody.
Brian Reagan,
ladies and gentlemen.
Brian Regan comic on Twitter.
What's your show this weekend?
I'm at the Dolby theater.
A Nla this Saturday night.
What time was this show?
8:00 PM.
That's the same time as the UFC.
Was the UFC in vi?
In La at the staple center?
Well,
I'm not saying it's bad.
I mean people are going to see you.
They could DVR the UFC.
Yeah.
You brought up the UFC either way.
Either way.
The Dolby theater,
ladies and gentlemen,
mass the place to be on Saturday night.
Fuck to you up saying I said I worked for them.
I'll be there.
Dolby theater Saturday night,
uh,
on Twitter.
Brian Regan comments.
He talked to people on Twitter.
Do you,
do you interact with the folks from your conversation?
I might need to adjust my,
my way of doing it right now it's been,
it's been kind of one sided.
I don't tweet a lot,
but it's just me tweeting out.
But you don't usually like read the tweets and then respond.
No,
I know.
I probably smarter.
It's probably a smart way to do it.
My way is probably ridiculous.
No,
I didn't.
I just tweet out and then we'll go make a milkshake.
Here's what's important.
You fucking hilarious.
You're a great guy.
It's always a pleasure to hang out with you.
Always a pleasure to have you on the podcast.
Never Seen Brian Regan live.
Please go check him out.
He's fucking absolutely one of the best in the country.
You're very nice.
Thank you so much ladies and gentlemen.
Dolby theater,
Los Angeles,
California,
Saturday night.
Be there.
Good.
I see you.
Bye.
Okay.
Hm.